and we do have a sponsor good morning
represent
Balden for the record my name is Amanda
Balden I represent Hillsboro District
25 um I sent an email L last night I
asked that you either kill this bill or
sit on it until the deadline just to see
what the Senate does with HP
173 and he's not here but I had a joke
lined up that I won't be taking any
questions unless they're from
representative Jared Sullivan and the
question is I told you
so but just to be clear hp1 73 you guys
already covered this with an extensive
Amendment and so this isn't necessary
unless the Senate rejects what this
committee unanimously passed that passed
the house on the third of this month
okay so so well yeah probably would just
interrupt study it so that we'll see
what
happens I think you have until March
21st to vote on this if you want toally
the Senate will take action before then
and this isn't the same as HP 173 but
it's same enough that you can do to what
you did to HP 173 okay if you want a
second bite at the Apple oh I see right
just we could do that too we've been
known to do that okay any questions from
the committee
members seeing none we thank you very
much for your testimony thanks enjoy
your
break right not
quite
uh yeah no problem uh Philip
Sherman and now you oppose the
bill Mr chair members of the committee I
I support the representatives of of you
as sidelining this we work with you on
173 so uh mostly here just in case or or
if there are any
questions right so you're 173 was the
right answer we don't need to yes
sir got got it right shorter the bill
the longer the sessions right yes
okay great thank you very
much uh is anybody else wants to
testify
on
1159 I don't know Mike I see you're work
you're working on you're all set okay
great all right then we will close the
public hearing at
11:59
yeah
chair and good morning everybody thank
you um for hearing my testimony I am
Jerry Stringham for the record I'm State
Rep uh representing Lincoln Woodstock
and Easton a heart of the White
Mountains including Lon Mountain
Woodstock in and at this time of year
the Ice Castles make a nice place to go
I'm serving uh my second term here um
I've invested considerable time uh in
issues impacting the disabled having
been um sponsor four different bills on
the disabled and um but my background is
is as a business person as a graduate of
Harvard Business School uh and I run my
own consulting firm for the past 25
years which has supported over 2 uh
startups in the medical device field um
so I understand businesses have many
rules protecting workers customers
neighbors and Society in general that
are important but they can be owner as
to Implement uh none nonetheless
business owners I found are very willing
to accommodate reasonable regulations
but ask that they be
appropriate uh which brings me to HB
11117 um uh you know we have you know
wonderful program uh here in the state
and Nationwide uh to support those that
are disabled by allowing them to bring
service animals uh into our
businesses um uh but uh some of the
restrictions on them have made it uh
difficult for the owners of the
businesses to differentiate those that
are truly eligible from those that are
that are not uh which makes it both
difficult for the businesses and for
those who truly need uh the access uh to
things like a hotel or a restaurant with
a service animal so I I view this uh
this bill as a program Integrity bill so
um with that as a background I'll
discuss the role of service dogs uh the
mandates for businesses created with the
Americans with Disabilities Act the
chaos created at certain businesses by
misrepresentations by certain dog owners
and requests by local businesses from
relief from those claiming their pet as
a service dog when they're not uh and um
uh they'll also discuss the original
Bill and an amendment
option um service dogs play a critical
role for many handicapped uh individ
idual with
disabilities and to help them live a
normal life this includes those
suffering from blindness hearing loss
and other physical and mental
disabilities a trained service dog
allows a disabled person to live a life
in a substantially improved way
compensating for these physical and
mental
limitations
um mandates to support the access for
service animals came nationally with
Americans with Disabilities act uh this
was passed in July of
1990 and is a comprehensive civil rights
law for people with disabilities the Ada
promises open access to public
facilities for those with these
disabilities among access provided
through the Ada is access to hotels
stores and restaurants federal law
dictates uh largely what is required uh
a two-page flyer is available on page
one and two of the package that I have
submitted this is available uh from the
state of New
Hampshire Uh current F federal law limit
States uh from requiring professional
training of service dogs uh requiring
any
license uh of a service dog specifically
although other than uh licenses that any
other dog would have to obtain and
allowing volunteer licensing use of any
particular gear so um to be a C A a
service dog in New Hampshire you don't
have to have the vest on you don't have
to have a little
tag um and um uh then the requirements
are are stated
here so I did notice you know I've
looked at this thing probably 20 times
before I came in here today and on the
first page uh on the right side service
animals welcome and uh you know there's
statement there about it's in it's
illegal to misrepresent your dog but it
actually says it's illegal to represent
a pet as a service animal so uh I think
they wanted to say misrepresent and it's
a typo and I I just just caught that
right before being here today so um but
anyway chaos created at businesses uh
the net effect of current service dog
reg registration is that dog owners can
largely self-certify that their dog is a
service dog and develop their own
criteria
um at least at least as far as
approaching a business I received
complaints from several business owners
about uh the abuse of required service
dog accommodation accommodations I'll
talk about Igor be he owns the Montag
cabins in North Woodstock he Renters of
the cabins arrived with their dog and
indicated their dog was a service dog
later he watched a tape at the front
desk where they looked up at the the New
Hampshire flyer provided and realized
there was nothing that montop cabins
could do and would have to accept their
representation uh he is out of the
country today or he would have been here
to explain how mislabeled dogs have have
been left unattended in rooms and bark
all day upsetting other
customers uh another example is a
restaurant owner described how
individuals brought a dog into a
restaurant sometimes with a service dog
vest that you can buy at Amazon and
proceeded either eat food off the plate
of another Patron or go to the bathroom
on the floor so um and finally a dog
trainer in Conway described the uh the
corruption and Chaos brought to the pret
uh PetSmart where she works as owners
mislabel their pets as service animal
and they proceed to get in fights with
other dogs clearly not trained the way
that the service dog Provisions uh
envisioned uh when put into law in the
1990s so the request by local business
is um you know all these people admire
and appreciate the value of having
access to service pets to their
establishments however there are dogs
gaining access and creating havoc in
their
businesses um in the case of the
restaurant owner she's no longer in the
restaurant business and she cited this
is one of the frustrating realities of
running
businesses um
so um some some of the more obvious
possible remedies were included an early
draft of what is now HB
11117 uh this bill is introd introduced
covers a committee to develop uh active
legislation it is not legal to require a
service dog be registered unless all
dogs are registered all dogs are
required to be registered in New
Hampshire once they're four months old
so registration is done through the
local Town
Halls at present most dogs register via
an online form uh I put together another
possible amendment to this bill uh uh
0308 um as a way to expand the current
registration to at least um uh provide
for people to optionally and on a
self-directed basis indicate that their
dog their their dog is a service dog uh
in I'll go ahead and pass this around
uh the in in this bill the the town
halls would include a reg would uh after
registration include a list of those
those dogs that are reg listed as being
service dogs and the Department of
Agriculture would create a publicly
accessible list uh while dog owners
could maintain that their pet is a
service dog even as if registered as a
regular pet when they arrive at a
restaurant uh it could help facilitate
uh better interaction and discussion
when individuals show up uh to make use
of the services of our very valuable
businesses um in a conversation with
commissioner Jasper he also felt the
Commerce Committee could authorize the
two separate license tags um be created
one for service dogs and one for
non-service dogs at present at
registration we only have uh one style
of tag tag again it cannot be required
by federal Americans with Disability Act
uh that service dogs have this license
but I see it as being friendly to the
intent of the Ada uh respectful for
those who really need access to the
services provided by the service dog
provisions and respectful to businesses
that when a New Hampshire licensed a dog
they indicate
whether or not their dog is a service
dog finally with current laws uh uh
allow service dogs to avoid paying a
license fee uh you have to go to to uh
uh the state house to to get that it's
strictly optional it's almost never used
um I I don't think it's necessary uh
that that be included in the amendment
but that's what came out of um OS when
they drafted this uh finally um uh there
there may be interest in in uh having
individuals uh classify their animals as
uh Comfort animals um which is not
service dogs um and um but some people I
think naturally U Mis Mis uh construe
that their very special dog uh is not
just a regular dog even if it's not a
service dog and I think having the
option of putting something in the
middle May
uh even though it carries no legal
weight above a regular dog may keep them
from check marking a box saying they
have a service
dog so um
Ive I've also included uh relevant
sections of the Americans with
Disability Act print out on service dogs
for your information
um and as well as you know you have a
copy of the bill and the potential um
Amendment and um i'' be happy to answer
any questions that you may
have okay representative
spear thank you just as a question what
are other states doing I mean we can't
be the only state that's in this do you
know
um you other states have different
definitions of what service dogs are but
it seems like every you know I went I
went through um um you knows and the
research support and there wasn't a good
bill that I could I could piggy back
on sorry representative
Gibbs thank you um I should uh back up
my question by saying that my whole
career was an equal opportunity law
first in uh with the state of New
Hampshire and then with the federal
government so I I know something about
this um and my question is um uh since
you're considering um this
optional uh special kind of registration
as perhaps a deterrent to people
incorrectly um misrepresenting their
dogs um uh which I agree has has been a
problem both for people uh both for
businesses and for people who have
actual service dogs um and and um you
know want to be sure that that's
recognized but might not the existence
of that special
registration um result in business
managers um uh
incorrectly um uh taking the position
that a dog without that special tag uh
or other special
identification uh in fact is not a
service dog and therefore does not have
to be allowed where a service dog could
go well I the the owners I've talked to
have you know seen seen materials like
put out by the state so
um
uh you know if the law is that they
don't have to have that it's just some
certific ification that gives them more
confidence that these people actually do
have a service dog so I um uh the
business owners I've talked to didn't
didn't seem to think that was uh I mean
they they understand the restrictions of
the federal law that a certification is
not
required other questions so um this
ironically uh this past week I was
confronted with a situation where I just
looked checked out my email and they did
use the term service dog and um in this
case I I do have a vacation rental and
um and the uh people should uh and I had
two different
customers and uh and one of them said
well fine we'll just do business
somewhere else okay because we said no
no dogs right and then the other one
said well gee I thought everybody had to
take service
dogs and so so I was thinking okay so
now we need to explain to this person
the difference between a service dog and
a comfort dog but my wife said no no
we're going to remind them that vacation
rentals are
homes and anybody's allowed to borrow a
dog from their home even a service dog
right and a real service dog can be
borrowed from somebody's home and that
that was the tax he took and the person
then came back and said well we do have
an RV and we could keep the dog in the
RV well obviously that is no longer a
service dog if the dog is in is going to
be left inside an RV so that subject was
ended so I guess really to tell you that
yes I I understand the stress but I you
know mean I myself personally um you
know my my original mother-in-law she
she was deaf and she had a service dog
so I knew right way back I mean I'm
talking 30 years ago about service dogs
and d a service dog has a special jacket
it literally says do not touch meh okay
that so that there's plenty of giveaways
if you see a dog that whether it's a
service dog or a comfort dog Comfort
dogs usually don't have that jacket on
they have some f cat on or something
something related to the weather so so I
guess my my problem is is that is
understand so this legislation you want
to have is for hot tellers to who are
uninformed who don't know the law and
that you want to have us pass some kind
of legislation to better inform them or
give them a better way because all they
have to do is say well if it's a service
dog you know obviously they can't ask
the person with their handicap cap is
but they certainly can say is where's
the dog certification and why doesn't it
have the have that special jacket on
there that says do not touch me so I
guess I'm I'm trying to you that's if
you are hoping legislation is going to
come out of this study committee that's
what I was hoping the you know the they
they a service dog does not have to wear
a service vest it does not have to be
professionally certified you can if you
have a sore back
I'm just give an example you have a sore
back and you teach your dog to pick up
your napkin if you drop it you can then
make the certification that that dog is
now handling an essential function for
you and that's a service dog and um and
you you know the the the the federal
laws have you know don't give us a lot
of leeway to um put a lot of
restrictions on
on um what is required for a service dog
to be a service dog uh such that um
restaurants and
um uh you know hotels are are required
to provide access for them until they
misbehave
so okay representative Gibbs has a
question yeah thank you uh thank you uh
what I actually have is a comment uh and
a suggestion um uh again having worked
in this field for many years um and that
is that anyone who is thinking of um
excluding a dog that has been identified
as a service dog whether it has a
special tag or jacket or whatever um
from a a home uh rental home hotel room
uh anything of that nature check with
the um HUD office of fair housing and
equal opportunity uh before you to
exclude that dog and get a complaint um
and similarly for a uh restaurant
manager check with the um us uh
Department of Justice Office of civil
rights uh you can also check with the uh
New Hampshire commission for human
rights which also works in this area it
really uh will do you a lot of good to
have the straight up information uh
before you get a complaint so just
trying to be helpful there yeah thank
you would you
believe okay representative
Grassi would you believe that I'm on
Amazon right now and I can buy a nice
vest and a card and a thing a tag that
says access granted by federal law for
less than $19 and I could put it on my
cat and call them a service dog I
suppose service cat um what service it's
in Amazon unfortunately I've got it
blown up to a size check the mice in the
restaurant in the hotel Back Down size
there we go I mean it's there are all
kinds of things you can buy and having
worked in the in the transportation
industry this is a big problem that we
have I mean I had somebody come up with
a little and we I I work in a bus bus
business yeah go right and the thing is
is that I've had people come up with
chihuaha and say this is a service dog
and you know you can't argue with them
in most cases because if you do they sit
there and they threaten you and it would
be nice that if we had places that had
assigned posting particularly with how
much of a fine you could get if you misr
I had somebody say that their boa
constrictor was a was a comfort animal
and of course Comfort animals are not
covered under Ada but the thing is is
that people think they
are right that was a would you believe
would you believe yeah but here's the
problem would you believe the federal
government says we can't require
anything to prove it yeah so we're we're
in a pickle here okay next question
represent Ammon thank you Mr chair thank
you for presenting this bill to us I'm
just doing some uh research on my laptop
here I Google it so I'm looking at the
US service animals uh.org it's the
official service and support animal
registration and there's a couple
paragraphs here it says it's illegal to
ask the Handler to demonstrate the
abilities or training of the dog yeah
yeah and I'll get to a question but I
just want to set it up here so I'm
looking at usservice animals.com it's
the official registry of uh service and
support animals and it says it it's
illegal to ask the Handler to
demonstrate the abilities or training of
the dog even if you don't see the dog
performance task the Handler also does
not have to produce any proof or the
dogs of the dog's training and you are
not allowed to ask about it and then
another paragraph says there is no
registration requirement or
certification progress Pro process for
service dogs the Ada states that any
required registration or certification
would be considered a form of
discrimination service dogs don't have
to have any form of identification
labeling them as a service animal so I
guess my question is if the Ada says
it's discrimination to ask how can we
enforce it
that that was my point yeah I mean I
think this is the kind of problem that
the the business owners have they're
told uh um only two questions may be
asked is the dog required because of a
disability and what task or work has the
dog been trained to perform oh you are
allowed to ask those question you are
allowed to ask those questions but you
can't ask to prove prove the trick you
can't ask them to prove it and um uh and
you know if they can't answer it I don't
know what that means so you are someone
allowed to ask the persons what their
handicap is because you're asking what
what your with the TK that makes some
sense because if the handicap is
something that you would have to make
additional compensations for as the
business owner right it it might be we
don't want anybody with a bad back
you'll complain about our
beds yeah you need extra extra firm
cushions right or mattresses so um and
you can't require you can require dogs
to be licensed but it's optional whether
whether they want to uh you can make it
an option for them to to make it a to
register as a service dog so that's
that's kind of why I came into the we we
we do require dogs to be licensed in the
state of New Hampshire every every year
and um but that doesn't mean they the
dog comes you renters my renters a lot
are mostly out of state that's true and
that's true we can't we can't require M
require require the dogs to be
registered they may come from
Massachusetts or you said most of your
uh out of state yeah most of mass is I
get a lot of mass customers okay
representative Gibbs again yeah thank
you um would you believe that a
Chihuahua can be a service dog for
instance um there are people who suffer
seizures of various types
and there are dogs that are trained and
I cannot tell you how this works but I
know that this this this is factual
there are dogs that are trained to
recognize when a seizure is coming on
and therefore in some way bark or do
something to warn the person uh the
dog's owner uh that the seizure is
coming on and thereby the person could
for instance sit down or lie down on the
floor and avoid getting injured so this
is is is more complicated uh than it
appears years um and also uh would you
believe that while it is legal to ask
what task the uh dog is trained to
perform that is different from asking
what the disability is that the dog is
trained to assist and it is not legal to
ask uh what the disability is thank
you okay so let me say Okay um juvenile
diabetes dog is trained to smell smell
your blood sugars that's right okay so
you're going to say what is the dog what
is the dog capable of doing the dog is
capable of of smelling whether I'm
having a diabetic attack you can't ask
the person to say show show me your
insulin show me that you really do have
juvenile diabetes no you really
can't I think there's nothing we can do
to solve this problem but I I guess
we'll look at your
Amendment see if that's somewhere we can
chase but
yeah yeah I think the just looking at
this um print out uh the F $1,200 can
you just post that as far as I know it's
it it um uh and and I did if you there's
a a sheet of uh near the back it's a
full
page um that you know I did locate and
uh one of one of the uh the cabin owner
does post this now it's sitting on the
counter on the front desk even even even
if nobody's ever been fined under this
provision right but somebody had a
decent idea to at least
yeah well this is great I got two
customers I can email this picture
to before they decide to get too mad at
as for our decision all right thank you
very much thank thank you for
considering this and go ahead question
oh we do have a another question
represent spe what what does disruption
mean I've been in restaurants where dogs
have just started barking and barking
and barking and they're wearing the vest
I remember one dog specifically wearing
the vest but it's just sitting there
barking and barking and it's kind of
annoying to everybody and very
aggressive that ain't a service if it's
sparking it's not a service animal I
mean excuse me it's not a it's not a
real a real one oh everybody knew it
wasn't real but how do you kick them out
you tell them say it's a $1,200 fine
yeah I mean I think it's time for you
when your your dog leave otherwise uh we
will pursue this $1,200 fine restaurants
are allowed to
allow uh animals into their facility
it's their choice and we're not trying I
I you know I'm not trying to address
those that that uh may have a policy to
allow non talking about the disruption
dogs yeah I mean
um okay go ahead representative
Walsh uh I guess my question is even
with this and in representative Spear's
example what is the business owner's
recourse to to go through with this
because they would have to prove that
that dog wasn't a service dog so how do
you go about doing
that representative Gibbs uh thank you
um again I think I can help out a little
bit with the earlier point about
disruption and speaking from um uh
having worked with this issue regarding
housing and that is while a uh landlord
cannot exclude either a service animal
or uh a comfort animal for a genuine
disability uh if the animal misbehaves
uh for instance barks all night and
keeps all the all the other tenants up
or uh does its business um on the
walkway and the owner doesn't remove it
uh in a reasonably prompt fashion uh all
of those things would be violations of
the lease and the landlord could take
the normal actions that a landlord could
take uh regarding any violations of the
lease so similarly um if the um uh
service dog uh interferes with the
normal operations of the business um the
owner would have the rights that the
owner would normally have I hope that's
helpful I would add you can do the same
thing to an unruly Patron
too call the
police okay thank you very much thank
you okay uh Mike Summers representing
the Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association is in support of the
bill good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association uh from the uh breadth of
the discussion I'm I'm sure you're
surprised we're in support of this this
has been a massive challenge for our
industry to deal with over the last
number of years but particularly since
the pandemic it has just spiral into a
massive issu for for our business
members um a lot of good discussion with
the committee but i' I'd like to kind of
give a couple of examples and kind of
walk you through some things and I'm not
going to purport that I know what the
answers to this problem are but I will
tell you that that is a very uh
significant problem so uh couple things
that were brought up specifically that
you know uh somebody comes to your front
desk as a restaurant and they present
that they have a service animal
obviously our our members and by the way
we put out regular Communications on
this particular issue because we get
phone calls on this issue all the time
um and so you know they will ask the two
questions is this a service animal the
answer is always yes yes it's funny how
few people show up and say no and then
the question is uh so what what service
does this animal perform for you and
usually immediately you will know
whether or not it's a service animal
because the people that it is a
legitimate service animal are happy to
have that discussion with you they
understand the challenges of business
the animals are well behaved it's
usually not a problem with those folks
it's the folks that are coming in with
their pets or you know so-called uh
Comfort animals um they get up in arms
and they start stamping their feed and
they huff and they puff and they carry
on um I'll share a story with you in a
minute of an instance which I thought
was just uh even above and beyond that
but um but there's a couple of issues
that arise from this right so as a as a
restaurant you have a food license under
State Statute if you have a food license
on your premises you cannot have
anything other than a service animal in
your restaurant a couple of years ago
this legislature did uh allow for dogs
in outdoor patio areas but it had to
have outdoor access at could not go
through the restaurant so that puts
these restaurants in rather a quandry
because if they allow something in that
this person said yes it's a service
animal this this animal does X for me we
can't ask anything beyond that now you
have an animal in the restaurant that uh
is doing goodness knows what eating from
plates you defecating there's all kinds
of things that happen and so you know
obviously at that point the restaurant
can take some action to then eject the
the person but the real issue with us
from there is social
media now you're getting tried in the
court of public opinion and you know
people don't bother to share that it's
not really a service animal I just want
to take my pet to lunch right no they
it's always a case of you know we
ejected etc etc usually it triggers some
sort of an investigation um it creates a
huge headache for for our business
members um you know I spoke to a
gentleman yesterday who shared a story
with me that I'll share with you but he
said that you know since the pandemic
you know prior to the pandemic over his
busy summer season he might have two or
three service animals now it's every day
and sometimes two and three times a day
and it's to the point where people will
even after he said nope we don't allow
anything other than service animals in
here that they go around the building
and they're trying to toss them over the
fence into the uh outdoor patio area
even though he said we don't allow that
um but this is the story he shared with
me yesterday and he was obviously quite
upset about it and this happened last
summer but he said that he had a woman
come to the front desk and represent
that that she had a service animal he
asked the question well what does this
animal perform for a service and she
just started huffing and puffing and
said I'm going to call the police and D
never did answer the question he said
well I welcome and by the way he has the
sign in the window that says is a $1,200
fine for misrepresenting your animal so
she called the police police came filled
out a report said she claims it was a
service animal he claims it's not a
service animal they've denied entent Etc
and so uh the owner of the business
asked the police officer so what what
happens now and he's like it's out of my
hands it's a civil
matter so as a police officer he can't
do anything about it either which I
think really gets to the heart of the
problem we have a $1,200 fine on the
books that nobody actually enforces so
I'm not even sure what the recourse of
the business owner is at that point but
to take it a step further uh honor about
November 1st he said he received a
letter from an attorney saying that uh
they he needed to uh send a check for
$330,000 to Plate this woman and make
the problem go away or they would bring
in the Federal authorities so he reached
out to his attorney so now he has
attorney costs he's got time effort and
resources invested in this thing
ultimately his attorney advised him not
to do anything because ultimately looked
like this was a case of somebody
misrepresenting of course he's heard
nothing since but but you understand the
frustration of a business owner who now
has dedicated I can't even tell you how
many hours uh you know heartburn police
officers times they have you know you
have social social issues or cost in
involved you have attorneys fees threats
he's so this poor business owner is just
trying to run a restaurant but this is
what he's dealing with you know and it
happens on the hotel side just as
frequently if not more frequently um and
now you have a situation where you know
most hotels would they make attempt to
if they have service animals try to keep
them in certain rooms so that you don't
have these allergy issues you can't you
can't restrict them from being in a
specific room but most of them are
pretty accommodating and they they're
fine so you you try to limit it to you
know 20% of your rooms um but then
obviously you have these situations
where you know people are showing up
with pets they're sneaking them into
rooms now you have a room that you
thought was allergen friendly is not
allergen friendly then you have a
lawsuit that comes from that so this is
a major headache for industry um I don't
again I don't pretend to have the
answers to this problem but I I I really
wanted to testify on behalf of the
industry because outside of a few wage
and hour issues this is becoming rapidly
becoming one of the number one issues
for our business members to deal with so
um I would uh strongly urge you to
essentially develop this uh study
committee let's work on this issue let's
get some smart people in a room uh you
know bring all the stakeholders into the
room to to try to figure out I don't
know if there's anything we can do but
frankly I think it would be fantastic if
we could do something even if it was as
simple as somebody was in empowered to
enforce the $1,200 fine I think that
would be a huge step forward because
right now it's it's a statute that has
no teeth and to add on to one question
earlier the um the placard that was
mentioned in previous testimony um I
think it was a year or two ago the
legislature actually authorized uh
Department of Health and Human Services
food safety division to develop those
placards and share them with the
industry we send them out on a regular
basis at least once a quarter um to put
them in the windows have them on display
Etc and clearly that has done nothing to
help us U I'll also say two last Quick
points the first one is one of the
issues that we deal with as an industry
is obviously we have a lot of out ofate
visitors and in some states like
Massachusetts they've given protections
to comfort animals well then people from
Massachusetts think that the Comfort
animal is therefore it's the same thing
as a service animal it is not and so now
we have to explain those situations so
that's a problem that you know sometimes
it works out sometimes not so much
um forgot my last point so oh and the
other issue is the retail sector has
really compounded this because they
basically said Uncle when I going to
deal with it bring all the animals you
want into the building well so that has
just made it even worse because now they
think that they have free right to take
their animals anywhere they please and
there is no restrictions when in actual
fact it actually creates problems for
particularly restaurant owners with
their food safety license all right I
will get off my sot boox and thank you
for your time happy to try to answer any
questions um so but the idea that that
we have all the smart people in the room
is a great idea uh but uh we not ones to
reinvent the wheel so um before we take
action on this bill can you find some
state
law find some other
state I will do my best yes I because I
don't I the idea of creating this Comm
you know study committee and and have
them go through all this and angst and
knowing you know that that sound to me
it sounds unsolvable but it's and I and
obviously firsthand experienced with it
but so I some some state has got to
solve it if they haven't then then it it
seems like U an act of fertility
I will uh yes and I will do some due
diligence and I will see what I can find
and bring back to you uh hopefully kind
of move this forward but um I will also
say that based on your personal example
um I suspect that could have become a
problem if they were actually service
animals because you're renting it out to
the public therefore it kind of changes
the rules under the Ada correct um
smarter people than I may be able to
answer we would hold out that we're a
house we're a
home just know that discussion when it
comes to Vacation Rentals which will'll
be continue to discuss in this committee
okay representa Aman thank you Mr chair
I was just curious if you have seen the
amendment and if you had any I have not
seen the amendment I do not have an
opinion on it at this point yes but I
plan to get a copy and review thank
you representative pelli clarifying
question
please until so I just want to make sure
I understand until some of the federal
laws are updated
that we're in this kind of uh precarious
position that we're really not able to
make any effective changes that would
not exacerbate the problem is that a
fair
statement that's where you're getting
into legal and not being an attorney I
don't want to you know necessarily speak
out a turn I suspect that certain broad
parameters will not you can't really
necessarily mess with those what I'm not
sure about is can you enforce what
you're on your books aka the 12 $0000
fine for misrepresenting an animal uh
you know licensing registration type
scenarios all their other activities
that could take place that would ease
the burden Andor uh deter folks from
misrepresenting at least to some degree
uh versus where we are right now and
again I'm not an expert I I can't really
speak to that but I would hope that
there might be some small steps we could
take to mitigate this
issue representative Gibbs now am I got
it right this
here where it says here office
Governor's Commission on disability is
that
you no that was not
meiss
govern okay what I was going to ask um
uh in reference to the proposed study
committee uh as it is um stated in the
original version of the bill uh it
refers to membership being members of
the house and the Senate and what I was
going to ask is would it be um would it
be agreeable to you if um in addition to
members of the house and the Senate
there were to be uh representatives of
stakeholders for instance uh
representatives of the hospitality
industry and also representatives of the
disability Community as specifically uh
a a representative of the governor's
commission um uh on disability and also
a representative of an organization such
as Granite State Independent
Living frankly we'd have no issue with
that I think uh all those stakeholders
would likely be involved in the
committee hearings themselves so I think
you know tomato tomato but but if you do
that I would also encourage that we
include somebody from the retail sector
because that obviously is a huge issue
for them as well although most of them
have just seeded The High Ground at this
point thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very
much okay having no more cards for 117
you want to check to see if there's
anything blue sheets on there represent
grass
SE okay we will close the public hearing
on
okay last
bill uh does anybody know who
represented
Alward
Howard did did I get one that's saying
that this bill wasn't necessary anymore
did I get a message from this I think
didn't I get some
oh
okay right so and they're not here I
would even know
talk that's right make you introduce
it
right didn't you do a farmers market
bill yeah there been quite a few farmers
markets anybody here to talk about
it nobody talk nobody here nobody that
would be the that would be J
put there only one sponsor
and no Co and nobody's
here
uh but I think I did I'm pretty sure I
did get yeah you said I got an email or
did we all get that email or did I
forward it all to you one from Amanda
that's what Tim was oh okay let me see
let me see let me type this name in a y
l w a r
d no
results
okay the bill
number I was looking in the wrong
account
ready
okay well open up the public Hearing in
on House Bill 1090 and hear from
representative Cole good morning
representative Cole you do have to fill
out a ping card by the way I'll make
sure I do that Mr chairman right
away for the record representative Cole
House Bill 1090 FN repealing the
requirement to register a farmers market
as a trade name like to recommend
itl any questions based on the sponsors
based on the sponsor recommendation yeah
yeah okay
Mr
chairman do we do we have any idea um
what the original intent was because in
principle it doesn't sound like a
terrible idea to repeal a requirement to
register Farmers Market as a trade name
like that sounds like maybe a good thing
but I have no idea on the background of
this spell okay so evidently I did
receive this January 7th is that the one
you're asked the sponsor okay so uh I I
so did I forward that to you okay so I
forward it to you so you actually have
this already Shazam and it says um the
hire house trade and commerce uh HB
1090 repeal of a statute relating to
trade name reg My Dear honorable
chairman committee members amendment to
HP 1685 related to homeowner foods and
definition of a farmer market were
recently made and as a result the
proposal to repeal is no longer
necessary the statute needs to remain as
is in the grand scheme of proposed
homade food laws in the farmers market
definition reform therefore I will not
be introducing 109 and requesting that
the committee vote itl thank you for
your kind consideration of this
request Deborah do I have to do somebody
have to move this could we could we just
move this okay so um
ISC I need oh we can't do this do it
when we ex all right
fine okay we're done so um just so
everybody knows I've always had the
habit of um not I disagreeing with the
idea of killing a bill on the same day
is the hearing I've always said every
bill should have 24 hours um before it
gets to death now so so at this point
you know we do when we do have our exec
um I I partly thought about doing an
exec session for Thursday afternoon but
I'm not think that's going to happen um
we will be exec next week okay and I
haven't figured out exactly what our
calendars but I would at this point I'm
going to say
um that would probably will schedule
subcommittees for Wednesday morning and
then exact on Wednesday
afternoon okay and so therefore and and
the bills that on was is certainly all
the early bills I want to get all you
get all the early bills out of out of
committee um and um so if you you still
have that original spreadsheet I sent
out it does say early which ones are the
early bills um I think we pretty much
have done all the subcommittees on them
but I will make sure that we will have
done those um I know we're you know we
are doing some
subcommittee um obviously this
afternoon Tuesday and so I will be
schedule for Tuesday so Tuesday I say um
I still want to be Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday I'm still want to stick to that
program um and at this point I would try
I know I'm we're down to one day left of
of hearings so I'll look and see what we
have for stuff to exec make sure we have
enough you know get the early bills out
on Wednesday if not if there's and like
the cannabis bill I'm just to have a
just to play play this out loud the
cannabis bill probably will have another
subcommittee okay and so that would be
we would either do that Tuesday or do
that Wednesday morning but that would be
cutting it down cutting it close for
executive it so I might not do it that
way um we're really in no pressure now
to get and that so that last day that's
that's day number nine so after that
then we've done all our hearings which
is uh remarkable that we were able to do
it so efficiently um and uh so but so I
would just say be be be planning on next
Tuesday and Wednesday there will be
subcommittees potentially hearings
potentially maybe a half days of
hearings um and then and then we will be
but definitely will exact I would say
Wednesday afternoon now um having said
that it would be helpful if anybody who
wants to uh bills that we have that
we're going to be executing to know who
would like to make the motion uh you you
those of you on that subcommittees that
that help there would be you can make a
motion it would be helpful um so anyone
who wants to um take make the Motions
please let me know um and but I have
been ordered and no un certain terms
that if you do make the motion you're
not allowed to leave the room until
you've written the blur
so
that am I am I quoting correctly I'm
sure be up to the Chairman's
descrip so normally I would would I
would say you know write it you know go
home write it on your computer and send
it to me but um they want to be very
strict about this about getting these
BBS done in time time because evidently
other committees have been very sloppy
about that so what I would urge you
again and and if you really want to make
my day look at those bills that we're
going to sub and decide which ones you
want to let me know and write the blurb
ahead of time and that way you can email
me uh as we execute and that and then we
won't neither one of us will get in
trouble for not getting it done on time
do you want us to email you that we want
to write on something or do it on your
computer right if you if you if you like
to make the the motion we can do it by
email to tell you you just tell me he
you want to do it and be semi semi it
should be people from the
subcommittee you
know
okay okay then I just heard that um I
will be looking to you to be making some
motion you are your members will be
making motions to take up action Y okay
I mean I think I can think I can think
one that's that that you guys made the
motion
on we would we would be executing on
Wednesday okay okay so certainly on
Tuesday I'll be you know trying to
gather out because I want you know do a
do be able to get out early on Wednesday
because we'll have everything exact and
get it done
quickly all right any
other okay so I guess we're done for
hearing today and and uh if you want to
Real Entertainment come back at 1:15 for
cannabis all
right
in the room we will invite him to come
up and speak uh because he was the chair
of the Cannabis commission that uh
started
this whole
thing this whole ball rolling so good
afternoon Senator
abis good afternoon uh Senator Daryl
abis I represent District 22 serving the
communities of pelum Salem Aon and
plastow uh I was the chair of the
commission this summer I had the
privilege of sitting with representative
hunt representative
Sullivan that am I'm missing anyone
that's on the committee but I want to
thank everyone for hearing me out today
anyway I did go back and was strongly
recommended I watched the last uh
Hearing in this committee about what the
commission did and did not do and what
and I feel like I could since I was
there I could provide you some insight
on what was talked about so initially we
were looking at a state control model
basically mirroring the liquor system
and we kind of transitioned that to a
franchise model now I will say that you
can call whatever you want but if it's
an agency Outlet my understanding that
getting when you get all these people on
the same page and from
different different chambers different
bodies different branches of government
and you start changing Provisions the
problem is the whole house of cards
collapses there's Provisions in here
that I'm not
necessarily supportive of not my first
choice but it was part of a very
difficult compromise that has been more
than a year in the making so even if
something's in here that I I'll give you
an example the 15
stores not my favorite provision my
understanding is if you deviate from
that to even 16 this whole thing will
fall apart I just that's how it is uh
the number was lower we got it up to 15
so you can
imagine how that was working out so the
idea is to start slow and you could
always expand on that but if you move
too fast you can't really go backwards
so really is airing on the side of
caution uh the future legislators will
always be allowed to change that number
as they see fit we won't have these
stores won't realistically open within
the next uh couple years anyway so it's
not something that's I would say an
urgent thing to deal with but the Dual
use concept uh we as a commission were
very clear that we were not going to go
in that direction to allow the Dual use
license for both a therapeutic facility
and a retail store instead what we
decided was why not allow every retail
store to sell therapeutic grade product
it would kind of make sense that you
would have it that way we didn't we
didn't want um any retailer to have an
unfair Market advantage over another one
and that was where the disagreement was
being raised so when we discussed that
it said well would that benefit the ATC
program perhaps because they'll have
more uh places to distribute their
product it seemed like we would limit
manufacturing they would kind of be
grandf followed in as the only
manufacturers of therapeutic gr product
but that to put us in a position where
not one single retailer had a market
advantage over the other when you when
you're a franchisee and you have a
franchise or you're kind of all working
together as a team and you really don't
want one to have be superior to the
other uh we we were not going to
legislate and it was I think the
commission was in full agreement we were
not going to guarantee any individual or
entity a license to be a franchisee now
there is a criteria in place for what it
would take that what would be be put
taken into consideration I believe when
uh the very first hearing we had uh the
uh the chairman of the The Liquor
Commission came in and testified to what
that criteria would look like on paper
an ATC would obviously be very favorable
to that but it wasn't going to we
weren't going to legislate and guarantee
an entity a license when especially when
you're going to limit the amount of
licenses we thought that wasn't good
legislation if we put that in any other
context I mean any one of you want a
license I might want I might want to be
Afra anise that would be absurd to put
that into legislation but if we go down
that road we felt that that was not the
right way to go so would they be a great
candidate yes and the reason why they're
a great candidate obviously they have
experience but also if you look at if
you're the the franchisee and you're in
the same town or same vicinity as a ATC
that's a that's a market
competitor all right you would be
basically essentially if they were to
voluntarily be asked to become a a
retail store store they're choosing to
go that direction you're essentially
you're not limiting your competitor but
when it comes to The Branding identity
of what the stores would look like it
would protect that brand you didn't want
some of your franchises to have these
two stores or dual stores inside there
and others not again that was the unfair
Market uh un unfair Market
competition my understanding was that
was what the agreement was when I say
agreement that was where we all came to
a
consensus and that was not something
that was opposed at the time by the atcs
that was my understanding I thought
since it when sounded so sure that I I
was wrong I asked other people on the on
the members of the commission we seem to
all had the same understanding what what
that was so things Chang no one's it's
not signed in blood that you have to
stick to it but that was what the
arrangement was uh we came to that and I
believe it's m Mr chairman you were the
one that said you can only can have one
master and the problem you're running
into is some when it came to enforcement
of some of the the therap the rules that
apply to the therapeutic facilities if
liquor was in uh The Liquor Commission
is now in charge of enforcement they
should be involved in the in drafting
some of the rules so it kind of became
what happens if you have a conflict it
kind of the overlap there was really
something of a concern uh some language
that we came up with after the
commission concluded its work was if
there was a conflict uh between the
rules that you would have uh Liquor's
rule would supersede the therapeutic
rule just so there's clear understanding
of what is in effect U when you're
dealing with with um the retail stores
so that's what the arrangement that we
came to was now I understand that
there's a lot of people that have a
different ideas how they would do this I
would do it differently Mr chairman I
know you would do it differently if if
it was just you we disagreed on a lot of
things during that commission hearing
But
ultimately we came to a consensus on
what we were going to go forward with I
will say proceed with caution by
changing the number 15 by changing this
to agency as opposed to franchise stores
in my opinion the whole thing falls
apart it doesn't matter which one you
think is better I haven't gone through
this yet I'm sure there's plenty of in
here that I'll I'll like this probably
things I would have done differently I'm
just suggesting by changing it it does
fall apart uh and it's not me that you
have to convince uh in order to support
this so with that being said um I'll
take any questions if anyone wants to
ask me anything about else the
commission did I will just say one last
one last part of this uh as part of that
agreement the therapeutic products when
they're sold in the retail stor was also
going to be subject to the royalty share
so the revenue would have actually been
higher estimated about 15 20% market
share uh it seemed to make sense that
that would uh that would in obviously
increase the state revenue but at the
same time by having more distribution
outlets for that therapeutic products it
seemed that there would be an increase
uh in sales as well so it seemed like
that was a win-win at least it was but
from what I gather from watching the
last hearing it doesn't seem like that
really isn't the agreement anymore so if
we don't have an agreement as far as I'm
concerned there's nothing requiring us
to mandate that therapeutic stores
become retail stores if you ask
me great uh representative
burrow thank you thank you senator for
taking my question could you explain why
this would fall apart if we had more
than 15 or if we went to the um agency
store
model so there was a lot of different
people and a lot of us I voted against
how many Canabis bills as a member of
the House Mr chairman you were there
representa you were there you listen to
those long boring speeches but I've done
it several
times there's a lot of people on both in
the House and Senate that have are
willing to come to they will consider
certain versions of this the problem is
with the agency side of this now you
have this dual license you have this
unfair market share the agency stores
have different meanings on the different
laws especially when you talk about
liquor but if it's not a franchise model
it's if it's an agency store protecting
the brand identity of what the
storefront looks like is is going to be
different you don't have as much control
over an agency agency store as you would
a franchise and when that was what the
agreement was my understanding that the
corner office was also on board with the
franchise language I'm not sure how they
would how they would react to this
agency language but when things are
presented cut and dry like that that
that changes everything but it would be
safe to say we're really not sure
exactly what agency store means because
all we can think of is agency liquor
stores which I'm clearly sure this bill
does not do that so we'll we need to
delve what you're pointing out is we
need to delve into figuring out what
what does that mean if it just means
changing the name from franchise to
agency then then no harm done if it if
there if there's something else in the
details then that's what we'll need to
learn yeah in in respectfully Mr
chairman if there's no harm done and you
just changing the name why change it in
the first
place um I I guess people don't like the
idea of the word franchise because I
guess there's federal law around
franchise and and they think we're
exposing ourselves to a uh a separate
statute that might cause us harm so what
what I would I what I would say in
respect to the fear of enforcement under
federal law we discussed that in the
commission we went over the Attorney
General's office provid us a lot of
instances where the federal government
has suggested they would do something
all that was presented to us in this
franchise model they they felt the risk
of the feds coming coming down and just
cracking down on just New Hampshire and
not any any of the other states was uh
reduced by not being a pure State
Control model but as opposed to the
franchise model but you call it agency
or franchise for the purposes of of the
federal law I don't think anything
changes you're just calling it something
different if that's GNA perhaps make
people feel better people feel better
about it then why not that's I I mean I
I'm not going to get into the semantics
until I find out what is actually in
this and if if this is about making
people feel better at this point this
this is not going to work I just I'm
just going to say all the fearful of the
all the work that went into this we want
to just change the name of something
because it we like it way it sounds
better right doesn't change any the
substance I think we're doing our job
all right representative spear was
next to ask the question Okay
so
represento thank you for taking my
question Senator are we here
representing the people the residents in
the state or are we just here supporting
the corner
office I'm here I can answer that
question for you and I'm here on behalf
of District 22 serving the communities
of pelum Salem a and plastow uh HB 598
from last term I did a lot of the
Drafting and to put that into place over
a lot of objections but a lot of people
supported it I'm doing this again being
a Bordertown my district from for the
most part is surrounded by five
therapeutic uh not therape excuse me
retail stores in Massachusetts uh if you
drive on the main road from uh ainson
into plastow you cut into one street
basically into Massachusetts for a
quarter of a mile and there's a
therapeutic uh excuse me a retail store
right there at that intersection so I'm
looking at it as uh a lot of the
potential negative uh social uh impacts
of a recreational policy whatever those
may be we may disagree on what those are
I'm already dealing with those in
District 22 that's why I support this
however getting this over the Finish
Line it requires us all to work together
so when we're working together as a
commission whether you're one political
party or another whether you're a member
of the House the senate or if you're the
executive office it's working together
it doesn't mean we're beholden to one or
the other so and if anyone knows me well
enough knows that I'm I'm only beholding
to my constituents thank you okay
representative
Gibbs thank you uh in reference to what
you said earlier Senator regarding um
control of the appearance of stores and
so forth why do we want to control the
appearance of
stores thank you for the question I
think the concept was that if you had a
franchise model in your franchise think
of any other think of a fast food
restaurant the logo what that does it
cuts down the amount of advertising
because you won't we want to limit
really the um we're going to limit the
types of advertising but also that's the
advertising is all going to be done by
the state by the by The Liquor
Commission so what to me one of the
worst parts of the states have gone with
a full recreational policy is they have
these large bright Billboards all up and
down the highways that for these retail
stores and that's something personally I
don't support that but by having them
all look the same and have the same
brand identity it makes the marketing
much simpler also that's where the
royalty comes into place that's why
every McDonald's has the same sign the
same symbol and there's some
restrictions on what the store can look
like also what you can sell there's a
reason why McDonald's doesn't sell they
don't want you selling hot dogs for
whatever reason that's their corporate
policy that's how it is uh further
question further question thank you uh
this is not a you know a hearing this is
just a
conversation that you're trying to
yes you can but please don't make it a
hearing
okay okay
um you said that um uh it would make the
marketing uh simpler um to control the
appearance of the stores but since the
most recent version of the bill as I
understand it basically forbids
advertising um and just about any other
form of marketing uh
then is that does that argument still
apply so the idea is that any marketing
towards miners was going to be strictly
prohibited to the extent they would be
any advertising it would be done and
controlled by the state that's part of
what their operation would be now we
didn't we didn't draft comprehensive
rules or anything yet because again we
were there was we kept kind of switching
directions on which
which road we were going to go down with
putting together a wreck policy but the
advertising side of things we just
figured if you did have any type of
promotional material that every
franchise franchisee would benefit from
that promotion and this also where I
thought the the market would go is the
money side of things is really the
individual products think of any liquor
you know you name your liquor right they
they don't own a storefront it's their
label on their product that's where this
eventually goes our New Hampshire liquor
stores have all the same sign same type
of logos if you see that so it's kind of
mimicking the infrastructure we have
it's not going to be exactly the same
but we're following that that route as I
as I understand it the latest version of
the bill forbids advertising all
together not just advertising to miners
so again if advertising is forbidden
does that AR arguments will apply well I
don't I'm not sure if it's where it says
that in and I'm assuming we're looking
at the same draft not the amendment that
was filed today yeah where where are you
referring to but if it says that I I'm
not against any form of advertising but
again that's something that that's a
minor detail that I think we can work
out I think where it gets gets more
controversial is the types of
advertising you're going to do all right
I I'm going to interject here
okay representative spear you have a
question to me no I have a question I'm
done with him you talk to me all right
I'll ask you yes why did the uh when you
handed out the amendment yes I this is
didn't representative Le's no not that
one the one you handed out okay which is
the one we understood came from their
originally from the commission correct
it had nothing in there about uh ex
exonerating people possession like ISS
yes yeah I commission intentionally left
that out
because the uh even with that
legislation marijuana wouldn't be legal
in terms of have of selling in or
legally present would be for another two
years anyways so the issue was that the
commission was more focused in passing
legislation to dealing with the issue of
how we're going to sell it how we're
going to allow license Manu you know the
cultivators doing all that
assuming that in the interim before it
actually was being sold in that
meantime that the Judiciary
committees who know much more about
legal process would have worked out the
inment issue that was the same thing we
had in our we had this conversation in
this committee a year ago that I said
this I don't want to do that nman we
don't know Congress doesn't know
anything about nman we don't know how to
do that and we can that's okay to let go
because it's not going to change
anything in the next two years because
we won't actually have legal marijuana
in the state I I will tell you that
there's been some progress with that so
keep mind we're up against a deadline we
didn't have the summer time to actually
meet that the commission wasn't formed
to the end of the summer so we didn't we
couldn't do anything in July and August
the language that was in HB 639 that
we had to work with that required the
court to vacate every single possession
conviction period the problem is the
court doesn't really have a mechanism to
go looking for cases from 1970
1960 the the way the analment process
works is someone comes in and they apply
for it they fill out a piece of paper
that's how they know where to find the
file so the language as written was not
something that would really work despite
how well intended it was but on the last
day of the commission and we figured we
weren't going to have time to focus on
that because it wasn't really the charge
of the committee but uh the repres the
person designated by the ACLU basically
clarifi the enement language to mimic
what we already have but Chang the
eligibility to The Possession limits
that would be in whatever legislation we
passed which is something that I was
willing to support but we didn't have
time to really uh work that out in the
in the commission but in the ACL is here
they can tell me if I'm I'm wrong but
that that's my understanding is at least
for my sake I was okay with the language
that was been proposed I passed that
around to the chairman as well so you
feel in general that the um if we ever
did come to an agreement right that uh
the fact that there isn't anything in
there about the annulment now that
doesn't mean we won't be able to put
something there something in an nment in
this amendment so that's a non-issue at
this point nment if we're taking if
we're discussing this amendment which
one are you holding up I'm holding up
represent
all right and at this point this is the
the sponsor bill this is the sponsor's
amendment okay at this point this is the
only one I'm discussing okay so there is
an in there if we don't pass this
amendment or we don't work with this one
thing get this one baby done we're not
going backwards okay we're not going to
look at anything else this is this is it
good okay not really to the I he is
telling us what happened in the Comm
okay I also just when I W in so he is
telling where we left off where we were
when came to December okay I I only read
the first two pages of the 30 something
pages so I don't want to speak on it
without reading yeah so let's just deal
with this document okay is he here
speaking because he was the commission
that was in charge but we're done with
that okay I'm sorry I guess she doesn't
want to hear anymore from I she she's
all done with you thank you very much
all right I appreciate the warm
welcome I Mr chairman if I can just say
one thing um in respect for myself I
wouldn't support any legislation that
mandates that any person entity gets a
license that's just me I say it again I
would not support any legislation that
mandates or that's any one person or
entity receives a license by operational
law license for to become a retail store
I every you you want the limited license
a little bit of a hint okay if you ask
me right I I guess U and and represent
Lan is here to introduce the bill so I
guess I I I have to say where I'm coming
from because you posed a what I consider
a very awkward question I mean are we
here for the governor okay no so in in
reality
is I am and you know why because I have
voted for marijuana bills I have voted
for multiple marijuana bills and they
all
died okay and when one of the reasons
they died is because the governor's
threat of veto and the governor
says
hey I would
sign if you did something like this I'm
gonna pay attention now maybe you don't
pay attention maybe you think well he's
a Republican and I don't care about him
okay but I I will pay I if it was John
Lynch saying the same thing when he beat
told marijuana and he said I think I
would sign this I would still pay
attention I don't care what you say
about do I'm doing this for my
constituents most of my constituents
have no clue and frankly don't really
have to care because there's two
marijuana stores that are are less than
five minutes drive away from their homes
okay so this it's really not about my
constituents it is about yes I believe
the state of New Hampshire should have
marijuana available okay and I think
it's high time that we pass something
and so yes I'm going to pay attention to
those guidelines those guard rails as we
like to call them that were presented by
the governor now if you want to say is
no I just want to pass what I want to
pass that's at this
point have at it guys there's been a lot
of work I you know and everybody keeps
saying you've worked so hard on this
John okay but my opinion doesn't matter
okay what matters right now is can we
put something
together that we can get out of this
committee we can get out of ways and
means get it over to the Senate and have
something that the Senate I assume will
be mucking around with
it and then we can can decide when it
comes back to us whether we can live
with it or
not and if we can we'll concur we send
it to the governor's desk and I would
assume most of us would hope that he
won't beo it and that's a lot of lot of
bites of the
Apple
exactly please thank
you okay pleas with the noise
okay now we're ready
repres I would say um normally I would
say let's go through this but I i' ask
you could you start by showing us what's
in here about the agency so that we all
we all are on the same page when we talk
about agency versus franchisee so you
can you tell us what where in here is
the differences between the two so we
have an idea John can I ask you one
question based on what you just said yes
assuming we wanted to be very practical
and we wanted to get something through
regardless of what it is not regardless
I mean obviously you could say no I
don't want anything and then that's the
end of that yeah
whatever we have plenty of people who
don't want to vote for any marijuana
bill I'm not talking about that
okay if we were to go to a spec because
both bills have a very different model
we don't know that we have we got about
to find out we're about to find out what
an AG model well some of us have looked
at this and you know exactly the
difference between no not exactly but I
know a little bit we receiv some stuff
yesterday
okay somewhat different model
okay I can understand that in the future
we could change the number of stores we
could change what the stores look like
we can change anything and everything
except that model but the model that we
will we would not be ever be able to go
back on that no that's actually not
necessarily true because it would take a
while take over a year before anything
to be in place you thinking that time
frame before it BEC that I I'm pretty
sure well unless he's changed the 18
month but the first license of of a
retailer wouldn't be issued until 18
months that's where it was I don't know
if it still is so if that's still true
that means we have a whole another
legislative year to second guess
ourselves and and change it we would
actually have next year to change
anything that came to it was retailed
and so actually to me one of the
important things why we really want to
pass something is that we want to get
the cultivators going we want to get
those cultivator licenses out there and
as far as I heard there is not much
debate about cultivator license so the
Sooners we get them out there the sooner
we'll know we'll have product to sell so
we can actually have
stores okay uh thank you Mr chairman um
I want to thank senator abbis for all
the work that he's done on this I'm
sorry that I wasn't able to try and join
that commission but it was a very
challenging year for my family and I
didn't want to commit to something where
I wouldn't be able to attend the
meetings um with that said um I heard a
lot of the concerns that he had and I
wanted to start off by addressing those
with how it's in the amendment and then
walk through those changes so you can
understand exactly what is proposed um
so his first question was um around the
concern about any retailer being able to
sell was about the market Advantage for
the atc's if they were able to open up a
storefront um within the within the way
that we have set up um actually you know
what that's gets so deep into how I'm
doing it I'm going to pause on that one
let's go back to the branding and
identity issues um we would be getting
doing away with any of that billboard
advertising and enacting a fine so that
even if out of state uh retailers were
advertising in New Hampshire they would
not be able to do that so that our kids
wouldn't be driving around and asking
asking Mom hey Mom what's cannabis
because it's on the Billboards so this
would be something where at least inside
the state of New Hampshire nobody would
see a billboard and there wouldn't be
any general purpose advertising it would
allow uh listing on weed maps it would
allow anything in Publications that are
related to cannabis so that anybody
who's seeking out cannabis most people
know that there are Publications that
you can go to they were in large
circulation well before it was legal
anywhere in the country and even if
somebody has only passing interest in
cannabis um there's a lot of knowledge
that you can seek out those locations so
the idea of having a market that grows
slowly and doesn't overwhelm with a
whole bunch of novice users I think that
the idea of not having advertising so
that we don't have it in front of our
kids so we don't have to worry about how
to standardize that between all of the
different all the different operations
uh would actually be a big benefit
because then it would be a slow uptake
of those um existing users or those who
simply aren't doing it because it it's
not lawful in the state of New Hampshire
it's a small population who are those
rule followers um but I think let's
start small and let's not start with an
Outreach of advertising that can always
be dealt with in the future once we
understand what the market looks like so
the idea of having consistent branding
for Billboards and for marketing going
from a franchise free fee is quite moot
if we don't have that advertising um and
then secondly we actually allow we
provide for rules around the finished
quality and exerience exteria of the
business and signs and Logo within the
regulation of cannabis so that even
without having a franchise model those
would be in the conditions for opening
up a retail outlet so that we can still
have that consistency so that uh we
don't have buds bud bud barn or anything
else that may be offensive to members uh
we actually also go um further to say no
slaying or promotion which encourages
over consumption so the idea of having a
sign with the bloodshot eyes and
something else that's encouraging over
consumption just wouldn't fly under the
licensed model we don't need to tell
tell somebody how to operate their
business um and if we can tell them that
they can't use you know crft or vulgar
images that are displayed to people
outside of their
Stores um as far as
um as far as the a I I guess I'm going
to go back to the whole idea of this
trying to represent the commission I
have been waiting um since the bill
filing deadline for the Senate and then
waiting through December and January
expecting that a bill was going to be
filed from the commission with the
commission's um report and with the Comm
commission's position even though the
official report because people abstained
didn't actually adopt a specific
language I was under the assumption um
that the chairman um Senator abbis was
going to move forward with this so that
he would be able to put forward
everything that they talked about over
the fall all of the hard work and to
reflect that with a bill going in
through the Senate to be able to address
the issues in the Senate and then pass
it over to the house to see if it was
something um in which we would partake
um but
unfortunately we have my bill that I
introduced with uh several other
wonderful co-sponsors we did this
because we weren't sure of the outcome
of the commission and that's why what
this amendment here today is trying to
bring this Clos to meet all of those
goals at the corner office while also
avoiding those risks which we do truly
believe are real about having too much
operational control over the stores so
I'll start with the objections um to the
what came out of the commission um the
biggest part is the high level of
control of operations in the rulem
authority which was in 318 F6 in that
amendment that included rules on the
size and nature of facilities including
store design
it included operation of the franchise
cannabis retail outlet it included
discount and compensation so what
discounts you could offer and how much
you can pay your employees and the
pricing structures for the wholesale
price of cannabis and cannabis products
that is dictating the operational uh
procedures and that is why um I am so
concerned that that model would trigger
um the number two of the franchise
definition to be a franchise you have a
trademark you have operational control
and then you have those franchise fees
you know we're going to have that
trademark we're going to have that
consistent look of the stores out in
front um and we're going to have those
fees that are coming through and we're
also allowed to have health and safety
regulations and normal government
regulations of a business without that
falling under a franchise it's that
operational control that is so dangerous
and so that is why we have presented
instead of a franchise model uh cannabis
retail outlet so um the amendment is not
a replace all the amendment left those
sections unchanged from the original
bill in the original bill which includes
the annulment but if you want to turn to
F12 and I'll tell you what page it is as
soon as I find
that sorry I got this um at 12:15 from
OS when I wasn't sure if I should send
out my rough draft uh for printing
so that is um
318f let's see it's in the definition
sorry sorry this one is the definitions
my apologies I was putting this together
with the information so it's right on
page three of the amendment starting at
line 27 it says the Cannabis retail
outlet or Outlet means an entity liks to
purchase cannabis from Cannabis
cultivation facilities to purchase from
manufacturing and limited Prof
manufacturers and to sell transfer and
deliver cannabis and cannabis products
to Consumers qualifying patients and
designated caregivers So within that
that is how we are defining it as that
retail outlet and then there are
extensive rules on the op operation of
those retailers that are within the
regulation section
so so when you look to those that is
where we have the regulation that has um
that has these
guidelines on how they would present
themselves to the public so um if that's
enough of just that general idea let me
give you the walk through with my
changes and the amendment I know it's a
lot I know I got it to you late I had
circulated some just with a couple few
people just for some proof reading and
we found numbering issues and
duplication so I thank everybody who
helped me with that so that I could
deliver the best possible product to you
today and so that we're focusing on the
issues and not on any of my errors in
drafting so we changed the purpose and
findings which are are now um very
reflective of what was in chairman
Hunt's Amendment um that's section one
of the amendment two and three just deal
with new references that are throughout
and we also adopted the name substance
use prevention treatment and Recovery
Fund as chairman hunt did um that's
throughout that's part of section
three um we had deleted the change to
the drug forfeiture fund because the the
Baseline data is being collected
elsewhere so that's an unnecessary
reference then in um
section section five which is the top of
Page Three we added harvesting and
cultivating to those things which are
not illegal because they're permitted by
state law that's consistent with the
hunt Amendment um and I believe the
commission work so that's definitely one
of the well done there so then we get to
the definitions um the hunt Amendment
had removed V vaporizing from Cannabis
accessories um I believe that's because
there's an assumption that we're talking
about either little cartridges or the
things that look like crayon that we
need to make sure that they're being
regulated appropriately um I don't
believe that includes any of the larger
almost desktop siiz things where
somebody's doing that in order to avoid
impurities especially if they're
particularly concerned concerned about
their lungs um so um those those larger
things I I believe would be fully
allowed under the language for inhaling
cannabis into the human body and if
there's disagreement about allowing
those larger desktop vaporization
devices then we'll need to add that
language back in um so we have the
Cannabis retail outlet there's a there
was a request during the commission and
also in Hunts amendment to add a
cannabis distributor so that's added
here but it specifies that it's not an
individual Standalone license where only
the distributor is allowed to distribute
if you're otherwise licensed you can do
that as part of your licensed activities
but it allows so that if somebody wants
to be a
distribution distribution only
Enterprise that would be licensed and
permitted um it also has in in order to
provide as many Market opportunities for
entrepreneurs as possible it adds a
limited production man limited product
manufacturing facility so the biggest
danger in the manufacturing is when
you're doing extractions with volatile
compounds I did a tour of one of uh one
of the facilities in a neighboring state
and oh my that is a science project
making sure that it won't explode when
you're using volatile gases to do it
let's leave that to the people willing
to take that risk but allow small
markets to develop things with the
extracts that they have so that Betty's
brownies or anything else that would
otherwise be allowed could be a business
for somebody to open up and for that
reason those limited manufacturing would
have a $100 non-refund fundable
application fee we've set an an applica
non-refundable application fee schedule
but have left the rest of the fees to Ru
making because let's at least get that
first line in the sand for where people
start I know on Jael car the idea of the
non-refundable application fees has been
a big topic so let's take care of that
here if we can um ads designated
caregiver just as chairman Hunt's
Amendment did um and we remove
everything on hom grow for therapeutic
cannabis there's already a separate bill
on that let's not confuse the issue by
including that here let's that let that
live on its own um it also adds the
definition and premises from the
Amendment and the therapeutic grade
cannabis product um so with that there's
we also have a provision for rulle
making that would happen sorry that um
we would have a provision for the Liquor
Commission the Department of Health and
Human Services therapeutic cannabis
program to work together to suggest
legislation to either transfer the TCP
into the liquor department partially or
wholly and then figure out what laws
would be required if uh therapeutic
cannabis were to be offered in other
retail stores
um I think that that would be a huge
benefit to everybody so that that
therapeutic cannabis could be purchased
and sold in those stores but because
there are certain purchasing limits
there's only a certain amount you can
buy within 10 days within the
therapeutic cannabis program that is
highly complex to roll out to all of
these different retail outlets so that
would be something to wait and get that
input from The Liquor Commission and the
TCP to figure out how to legislatively
enact that before these stores are going
into into force and quite honestly that
seems like a great place for the
Distributors so I'm seeing some of these
great Market niches here um let see then
the enforcement Authority we had only
had one sim paragraph sub paragraph in
there we added just about everything
from chairman Hunt's Amendment though we
did not allow them to interpret statutes
and rules um generally there's a certain
amount that's allowed within normal
practice but we don't want to supersede
the Judiciary branch and we don't want
to overstate the roles of the commission
so that language was problematic so that
was removed here um and as was the Rules
of Evidence you know we we could be
looking at from pretty serious impacts
on people um through the enforcement and
the idea of not having the Rules of
Evidence um seems problematic to me you
know if that needs to be a later
discussion it can be a discussion but I
REM that was removed because I find that
quite
troubling and then we have the Cannabis
Advisory Board
um that combines the members of both um
the initial 1633 and the hunt Amendment
which creates a very large very very
large Advisory Board and we need to make
sure that it'll be functional so there's
a few things that U reviewing different
advisory boards within my committee
Health and Human Services I've noted are
starting to be suggested to make them
work better one is that when somebody's
term has expired until somebody else is
is in that position they can still
attend the question then would be
whether or not they're considered part
of Quorum you know that's one of those
issues that can be dealt with and be
figured out but I think that allowing
them in unless they are removed for
misconduct or for um absenteeism I think
would be beneficial to the function of
the ad of The Advisory Board there's
also the issue of making sure that that
that people actually show up once
they're on a commission I'm on some
commissions where sometimes they're not
able to meet because either they don't
have enough people named or they don't
have people showing up so there's not a
quorum just for a regular meeting so it
defined Quorum as a majority of those
who've been appointed not a majority of
those that that exist as potential seats
to be filled and it also only requires a
quorum for voting so that the whole the
whole Advisory board or any
subcommittees which are specifically
enabled within this are able to do some
good work and that's quite important
because one of the areas we charge The
Advisory board with is looking at new
scientific evidence so that that can be
incorporated that's a great thing for a
subcommittee we don't really need 50
million people together discussing that
evidence so let's figure out how to make
this functional and
beneficial so it also add some charges
um and Inc increase in Outlets or canopy
limits uh advising on the potential need
for a state Reference Laboratory or
collaborating with other states
reference Laboratories if that's
possible and um it removes the
advertising oversight because we're not
going to have advertising so it's
unnecessary but it adds the ability to
advise on packaging and signage so now
we get to the regulation of cannabis
it's uh 318 F9 in this bill
and let me tell you what page that
starts
on 11 11 thank you very much ah yes
right there in the middle I wish there
were spaces between those uh those
chapters so this uh has a timeline
between the original and that which is
in the hunt Amendment um there would be
rules for dual use within 16 months
months so that we would know how a dual
use would be able to function and then
they can apply to get that dual use
certificate there's rules for
cultivation within 18 months so that we
can have cultivation sooner and then
rules for licensing and regulation of
the Cannabis establishments within 20
months so that makes it so that
everybody's ready to come out of the
Starting Gate to apply for those retail
outlets um after that you know within 20
within 22 months the there's also a me
mechanism for selection if there's more
than 15 applications for Outlets because
we left it at the cap of 15 um we did
say that if there three atc's the three
operating atc's um have a license that
an application that would be accepted
that they do get those they did break
the ground here we don't want to give
them an unfair Advantage but we also
don't want to kneecap them and make them
have to create a whole new separate
store you know we need to respect the
work that was done while making sure
that we're not giving any unfair
advantages and there's quite a few areas
in here that we look to make sure that
we're not giving them an extra jump on
anything
either so we added the disqualifying
conditions for lure from the hunt
Amendment um let's see there's rules to
assess the need for more stores at least
each year Geographic restrictions of one
per municipality or one for every 15,000
in population in the municipality and
1,000 ft from schools it still follows
Municipal zoning laws um within
cultivation rules it would um have them
develop a canopy cap if that's necessary
and um both the outlets and cultivators
would need to either open or make
significant progress and show why they
haven't yet opened within a certain time
period for their license to remain in
effect um that's to prevent anybody from
getting a license and sitting on it you
know this is going to be a really really
small Market with only 10 licenses um
it's one of those areas where we need to
make sure that if somebody has a license
they're actually moving forward and
making progress yet giving Grace
understanding that sometimes the
unforeseen happens obviously we would
have accept expected a delay if Co hit
in the middle of this
implementation so there's distribution
rules according like the hunt Amendment
removes the event in special use there's
restrictions on Advertising like logo
signage and marketing no General social
media marketing um as in the hunt
Amendment no slang or promotion which
encourages overc consumption which is
one of our additions in order to try and
quell those fears about what any
marketing may have there's a naming
convention where it would be a New
Hampshire retail cannabis Outlet or New
Hampshire cannabis Outlet it also could
be the dairy cannabis Outlet since
two-thirds of people in Dairy supported
legalization on a recent ballot measure
and uh would allow that if the Liquor
Commission approves you could have a
name where it would say uh John's craft
cannabis a New Hampshire cannabis Outlet
so that there could can be some
differentiation so that you know which
one that you're going to but not so much
that it creates confusion you know when
I go to a liquor store I didn't know
until I spoke more to uh some of the
representatives here that the one in
londondary has an amazing high-end
selection and the one that we've secured
in Dairy we need to show that we have
those tastes before we have that liquor
selection similarly in stores in
Nordstrom I had to figure out which one
sells clothes like this and which one
has more of the urban wear and which is
more the soccer mom when it has the same
name it's kind of hard to know which
store to go to to meet your needs it can
still be within the same umbrella and
and Clarity but if instead of saying oh
you should go to the cannabis store and
upping because that has a wider variety
of gummies and I know you like gummies
you can say oh let's go to I don't even
know what a name would be that would be
appropriate with gummies with that but
basically if it was you know if it was
Sally's kitchen um a New Hampshire
cannabis Outlet if that would be
acceptable to anybody then at least you
have a little bit more
differentiation and I see you probably
don't like Sally's kitchen and I'm okay
with that but some differentiation
because without the advertising you want
to have at least some Nuance to those
names um we have the we we decreased the
milligram content for Edibles and
drinkables to 5 milligrams and we added
100 milligram per package which is an
industry standard um there are are some
areas with 200 milligrams per uh per
packaging but let's stick with the
industry standard of
100 um let's see the packaging and
laboring rules from the hunt Amendment
so there's a Prohibition on poly drugs
that was already in there but that
specifically adds alcohol so that you're
not adding it to alcohol or anything
else to make it more
intoxicating um there's uh potency
limits are are would be done through
rules with advice through the from The
Advisory Board and public comment
remediation for testing regularities Min
minimum testing requirements and that's
important because if you have different
moisture content when you're testing
apparently you can have a different
level of THC in that test so if we know
what our standards are for testing in
New Hampshire and each of those testing
Labs knows that you need to test at
whatever the parameters are to have have
similar and equivalent tests then we can
those can be set through rules um
there's also rules on changes in
ownership to prevent flipping but
perhaps that should be a little bit
tighter if we only have 15 licenses if
we're not sure it's going to expand then
maybe we want to go to the Chick-fil-A
model on that where if you change
ownership it reverts back I mean maybe
you can collapse and have somebody leave
and have somebody remain with more
partnership I don't know we can run into
problems when we only have 15 but I know
that that's what that's what the
governor's looking for so we'll just try
and figure out how to work with that the
best we can um it also includes INX
ating hemp to be regulated in a way not
less restrictive than cannabis and as I
said before the Liquor Commission and
Department of Health and Human Services
therapeutic cannabis program would work
to help draft legislation to transfer
all our part to the commission and
integrate the offer the therapeutic
cannabis offerings and non-c operated um
Outlets um so then in 318 F10 that is
where we have the advertising Li
prohibitions on Advertising cannabis
sales that needs to be in more than just
rules because the rules only apply to uh
licensed operators and outof state
cannabis operations are not licensed in
New Hampshire so by having a Prohibition
on those advertisements um then and with
those fines that would allow it to have
an EV equal playing Ground playing field
so that we don't have out of state
interest uh buying up billb barns when
instate
cannot so and then it has a dual use
certificate pathway that is based that
should be faster just because we need to
make sure that we know what they need to
do they're already in the business let's
figure out that dual use and then let
them let them enter into that whole
process for the retail stores in the
same time as everybody else um licensing
procedures to accept and process
applications no longer than two months
after rules are issued but extend the 90
days to issue the license to 120 days
because there likely will be more than
15 um applicants and we want to make
sure that there's some time for them to
really assess and make any comparisons
necessary or to run a lottery and know
how they're going to be able to allocate
these you know we haven't prescribed
exactly how they will deal with an
excess of applicants um but it's quite
possible that they will need to deal
with that um also in the hunt Amendment
the municipal votes uh were on all
cannabis establishments and it didn't
state that it needed to be on the ballot
November of
2024 um I know in my town I'm sure that
they'd put it on the ballot regardless
of how the individuals who would be
doing that feel because they know that
the people of dairy want legalization
but if it doesn't say which which
election it needs to be in if you have
the people who are in charge of setting
up that ballot who are against it they
may not actually put it on the ballot
that first year and it may be delayed
and so for consistency sake it should be
on the ballot everywhere November 2024
and allow for a petition in the future
if it
fails um residency it adds that the
establishments must register with the
secretary of state with a principal
place of business in New Hampshire just
to keep New Hampshire cannabis New
Hampshire information materials and
medical lock boxes we're adding the
standard symbol for products from the
hunt Amendment and also adding the
requirement for medical lock boxes to be
honest when I first read that it scared
me because I thought we were talking
about something really complex like I've
seen with medication coming out at a
really expensive crazy machine or a safe
I Googled medical lockbox and it looks
like the little cash boxes you see at
Staples that you have at yard sales or
at girl Scott cookie bries if that is
what we intend as a medical lock boox
something that keeps out a curious kid
then I see no problem with stocking that
in the stores and you know what a great
way for somebody to carry their products
home
right um and then we also have the
lawful operation um it just flows
through adds the new entities and it
adds a equal starting gun for Outlets
once there's Supply to open there's
definitely been concern about the idea
of not opening any Outlets until the
liquor Liquor Commission certifies that
there's sufficient Supply to operate but
that's the reason that that's in there
is to because one we know that they're
not going to be doing anything to
handicap this Market opening when it's
ready to go you know they're they're not
going to sit on it and they're not just
going to wait and delay on it I have far
more faith in them than think that they
would do that but number two that means
that the atc's um that in this bill do
get one of three of the 15 licenses
assuming that they meet all of the
qualifications and filing deadlines that
um they are not starting any earlier
than anybody else so that's one of those
areas where we're bringing it back to
make sure that it's fully
fair and then proof of ID it adds the
requirements on licenses you had as your
enforcement activity verifying
non-compliance um we did change do a
change in the oplc language to
misconduct instead of malpractice I
talked to um
to I talked to director Lindsay about
that and uh or director Courtney about
that and um and she preferred the word
misconduct instead of
malpractice um data collection I've I've
just found out we probably could do a
better job of uh of specifying what's
necessary and who is responsible for
that so um if if you'd like I can try
and come back later with a little bit
more on that but that'll just be a
Nuance as we move forward and then it
moves to an agency fee instead of the
rooms meal and cannabis so we're looking
we put in 10% I know that the commission
was talking about 15% but this also is
the policy committee not the finance
commit the financial committee so if we
move over with an agency fee to Ways and
Means then they can figure out if 10 or
15 is the right number over there um so
I think I think that I would just take
the fact that we've moved to an agency
fee which is structured very similar to
that franchise fee and hopefully
hopefully you can take that as a win
even if the actual number filled in is
different since that is more the domain
of ways and means than Commerce uh
finally in the control Drug Act
definitions um we link it to the
marijuana definition in the new uh
legalization of cannabis and we remove
the deadline to act for conversion from
nonprofit so I know that was a lot to go
through um and I apologize that it came
to you just today but this was the
fastest we could do it this was a pretty
substantial rewrite in six days and I'm
happy that we were able to get this to
you in the form that it's in and um I
would be I guess the other one other
thing I gave you another piece of paper
that has the current DUI laws um as far
as cannabis DUIs people are already
getting arrested and already serving the
consequences of a cannabis DUI you do
not need to test to a certain limit in
order to have a DUI and the consequences
are significant including never being
able to go to Japan having to apply to
get into Canada and not being able to go
to Mexico for 10 years if you have a DUI
so it's even more than just what the
state puts on top of us um so with that
I'd be happy to take any
questions okay um first of all for the
Department of Safety in their section so
you will work with them to get that
paragraphed out yes I'd love to get
language from them that would work so
that we can do that they probably want
to may want to may want to address a
couple of those challenges as well so
you want to do do you are willing to
write something for her to correct it or
are you expecting her to give you
something uh I wasn't expecting to write
anything but I can provide ches
we
Bas okay now are you in the department
of safety is that where you're under yes
okay right well the other guy looked
like a trooper but you
know
okay okay so I'm just going to assume
that that paragraph We have get an
amendment for when obviously meet again
next week so we need to have that
straightened out for next week okay all
right any other comments or questions
people might have
yes uh thank you commissioner hunt um
and thank you for taking my question one
thing I'm a little confused about is uh
you in in one line I see uh if the
commissioner approves your license and
then another place I seek the
commission who is actually going to
approve somebody's license and what what
sort of criteria is there any like
Financial bonding or something that
somebody needs and I I guess I'm a
little concerned that there might be uh
a little bit of favoritism one way or
another if if a single person is making
uh approving somebody's license and
disapproving somebody else's if you can
explain that process um thank you that's
actually a great Point that's one of the
areas that was going to largely be left
with to rule making but anything that
you would want to set in as guard rails
I think especially if there's some
inconsistency in the language if you can
follow up with me to just help me find
those I'm I'm going a little bit
crossided from reading through this
probably a hundred times over the last
six days if not more um and I apologize
for missing that but I would love to
standardize that language to make sure
that it works I do know that in some of
the things in the Department of Health
and Human Services
it's um the commissioner or a design um
but we'd need to figure out what would
be the appropriate section there and the
appropriate person to approve it but I
do recognize we have an amazing
commissioner right now but um just like
I say with other departments just
because the person here is amazing and
it doesn't mean that the next election
will be as great so let's make sure we
legislate for to Future proof it and not
just rely on how amazing our current
people are thank you represent
bullo thank you for taking my question
the um the amount of stores that would
be licensed initially 15 is there
provision where you know within a a year
or two there could be 20 or 25 or is
there a limit of 15 and that's
it um thank you so in the um so in the
The Hunt amendment that had come out it
had said 15 for five years and then
reassessing every five years in this one
it says 15 for for 30 months to consider
to see how many are necessary and to
review it every year um and that's the
commission reviewing that just so that
they can be more adaptive to the market
because you don't want to tie their
hands so that if suddenly we noticed
because there's areas of the state that
don't actually have Supply through these
retail outlets and if we find that
there's more of an illicit Market in
those regions it may actually make sense
to increase that because that would be a
public safety issue um but it also
doesn't require them to increase that
number either
thank you I'm trying I'm trying to split
the
baby cut that baby in half okay anybody
else seem to be losing people here okay
great thank you okay thank you all right
uh this uh chairman do you want to have
any First Impressions or you have want
to say anything what you've seen or
heard so
far okay anybody else would like to uh
comment on what we you've heard or seen
so
far don't make me mad at you
again I'll try to be less than
that I
wish uh Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to make one point um and that is um you
know I view this as I'm really uh
entirely in accord with chairman hunt on
this you know I see that we have
basically um you know three um uh
Solutions uh bills formats whatever one
is the franchise model um that was uh
you know basically um promulgated and um
and suggested by the commission and uh
and uh leadership and so on um which um
is uh the franchise model we have the uh
we have 1633 that was originally
submitted um you know to this committee
um and then we have um representative uh
L's Amendment um basically I think it's
really quite simple um we have uh two
bills that are essentially non-starters
and one bill which is a starter um you
know and by that I mean it is a it is a
decent foundational beginning um and
it's something I think that can pass and
when I say that um I mean that the
franchise bill is a nonstarter because
it's legally nonviable as it's written I
pointed out some of that the the last
time I had an opportunity to speak we
don't need to go there and I'm not going
to go there again I'm just say I'm just
referencing that and the um the um
franchise model um and the um and 1633
is politically unviable and so it's a
non-starter so really my point is that I
think that by simply changing the
language from franchisee to either
cannabis outlet store or licensed agent
or something like that that we avoid all
of the liabilities and issues and risks
that I had pointed out the last time um
and I think that that would be a a path
forward to to laying a foundation for
legalization so how's that three minutes
right great thank you yes sir okay
questions no okay thank we're not having
a
hearing thank you I'll be I'll be brief
my name is uh Daryl e I'm the the
founder of the New Hampshire cannabis
Association um we did submit one very
short thing today it's about a three
minute read if you want to understand
what we're talking about not in terms of
State Stores or franchises it's really
concepts of of risk and plant touching
cannabis entities versus cannabis
related businesses versus other and this
will go through that very quickly so you
can got to kind of get a concept of
where this model fits within the risk
profiles of about the four different
licensing schemes that we've been
talking about and then at the bottom is
just a very short bullet point list on
how this threads the needle to meet the
governor's criteria and so I think the
melding of these two concepts uh was was
a lot of hard work but I think it has
been accomplished here so just recommend
if you don't mind two to three minute
read give that a look and if you have
any questions by all means reach out
thank
you
you Mr
seeds go on
up
seeds seeds are
us Advisory Board of uh New Hampshire
cannabis Association and darl E just
mentioned comparison that we put
together and I I would just like to take
a moment to compare how this amended
1633 uh meets the criteria that was the
charge for the commission because it had
very specific
requirements and it the commission uh
shall study the feasibility of
establishing a state controlled system
to sell marijuana to adults 21 years or
older that allows the state to control
the distribution and access well this
bill as amended does put the state in
control of Licensing regulation
distribution and access so it meets that
criteria keeps marijuana away from kids
and out of schools and the bill contains
numerous Provisions to prevent persons
under 21 from purchasing cannabis and uh
pre prohibits cannabis establishments
from being located near schools so it
meets that controls the marketing and
messaging this bill has numerous
restrictions and even some prohibitions
on the marketing and advertising of
cannabis and cannabis products prohibits
marijuana miles or
oversaturation this bill puts a limit as
we've heard of 15 on the number
Statewide of retail stores and uh giving
the Liquor Commission and municipalities
the power to approve uh all licenses as
another criteria empowers municipalities
to choose to limit or prohibit uh
establishments and this bill requires
municipalities to vote in the
affirmative in order to have retail
establishments and reduces the
incidences of multi-drug use it
establishes funds and mechanisms for
drug abuse education prevention and
treatment and now here's the one that I
only give it a half check mark does not
impose an additional tax so so as to
remain competitive this bill is called
an agency fee of 10%
uh but it would impose a new tax but the
other Bill uh that the commission was
working on also had a 15% tax so those
two uh are different but they uh you
know with this one being more
competitive uh but they both do impose a
tax and raise uh considerable funds and
finally I'd just like to make uh one new
point and that is uh I just became aware
of a new uh research report put out by
the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention uh looking at uh youth
cannabis youth use after legalization in
Washington state and uh they studied the
uh eth graders 10th graders and 12th
graders rate of cannabis use prior to
legalization and then what happened
after legalization and here's just a
paragraph I'd like to read from that
study study the observed overall
decreases in cannabis use among students
in grades 8 10 and 12 might be
associated with changes in the
availability of cannabis among persons
aged over 21 as well as limited
opportunities to engage in use the
period 2012 through
2014 includes the legalization of
non-medical cannabis in Washington state
in 2012 researchers studied the
association of cannabis laws with
cannabis use among high school students
and have observed similar declines in
cannabis use after legalization of
non-medical cannabis the legalization of
non-medical cannabis for adults aged
over 21 in Washington with decree with
licensed dispensaries requiring proof of
age might have affected availability of
cannabis to younger persons as well as
their opportunities to engage in use and
I attended most of the Cannabis
commission hearings and we heard a lot
of concern and rightly so of whether
legalization would increase the use
among young people and actually the
Center for Disease Control research is
finding that just the opposite is
happening in other states so it's
certainly not a foregone conclusion and
I've sent the link to that report to the
chair and uh encourage you to take a
look at that uh because I think it's
pretty revealing uh very interesting so
thank for you for your time and thanks
for all your hard work on this okay
thank you all right yes sir come on
up uh good afternoon everybody my name
is Ryan Nicks uh I am the supervisory
intelligence Analyst at the New
Hampshire information analysis Center
our Center as mentioned uh in the origin
original drafting of this bill and it's
also mentioned in the most revised copy
so I wanted to take a moment and just
speak to the statutory obligations that
have been outlined in the bill and how
that is uh more or less doomed uh from
the start just in terms of what we are
legally uh allowed to collect or what we
by base of policy and procedure have
access to collect um I've worked for the
Department of Safety for 11 years um my
politics aren't relevant nor is my
really position on this bill I'm
speaking specific to what are outlined
as mandates or uh statutory expectations
of what our Center can or cannot do I
would politely bring you to page 30 line
28 is what I'll be speaking to and in my
seven years of working uh at the
information six years of working at the
information analysis Center I spent all
of that time in some way shape or form
responsible for the oversight of or the
publication of the drug monitoring
initiative the data sets that go into
that its history and its perspective
Outlook um that's a longer conversation
but even just in the first few lines
here uh no later than six months after
the effective data this chapter and
every two years thereafter we shall
produce a report uh that speaks to all a
bunch of subsequent uh Health and
Welfare
outcomes I just would like to bring you
back and show you a brief history of
kind of the drug environment report and
the drug monitoring initiative if that's
okay sge
um that started as a request in the New
Hampshire Chiefs of Police Association
in the fall of
2013 directly in response to increased
law enforcement reports or reportings to
fatal and non-fatal heroin overdoses at
the time uh that took approximately I
believe 11 months uh to get up and
running and simply identify the partners
and the memorandums of understanding and
the uh memos of agreement between
agencies simply within the department of
safety for data collection then it took
us an additional I believe 9 to 11
months to get that public out for public
consumption so simply within the
department that took approximately two
years to identify and Aggregate and put
together all the data and collect and
identify those sources to produce that
product mostly within the department
itself not including the office of the
chief medical examiner the Department of
Health and Human Services Bureau of drug
and alcohol Services etc etc um so from
the first line here within 6 months of
passing this bill or enacting this
chapter um we would simply I would not
be able to meet that obligation to you
and then subsequently there are policy
and procedure as well as statutory um um
barriers to fulfilling some of these
requirement that I uh certainly not the
most educated to speak on uh but I felt
it was worth coming here being the one
who um QA qc's and oversees that product
as well as the one who's put it together
for the last several years to just speak
about some of the statutory expectations
that um are put on our Center and how we
will not be able to meet those um and I
look forward to continuing the
conversation and answering any questions
that you have so um so really it should
be two years to get your first Baseline
right uh at least right so I mean after
two years you'll have a you can then be
looking back where when when the bill
goes into uh if I could interject for
one second of the information that
currently appears in that drug Mar
initiative is actually owned by somebody
else it is not owned by the IAC it's
owned by the chief medical examiner
officers uh DHS uh drug and alcohol uh
service and uh division of EMS so they
have a actual uh way to collect that
information they're the ones doing the
surveys they're the ones receiving this
information they're able to provide us
with that data set that we can then
produce a product to show so okay so
would it be better if we just take all
this out here and say
every two years after effect that you
can give us a summary on anything you
think that would be relative for us to
understand the marijuana consumption in
the state only if there is a viable data
set of information that we could analyze
that's a lot of potentials and
hypotheticals that I'm probably not
positioned to speak to or answer today
right well I just wondering how would
you rewrite this because obviously that
they wrote this all hoping you know
fantasizing that they could get all this
data but as we all know that those data
points were probably impossible
obviously you know high school you know
rate adult rates of alcohol I mean I
mean how would anybody know any of these
numbers but you know these surveys that
are taken out there but yes
representative
Calabro haven't been the QA medical lead
at Harbor Care Health and Wellness
Clinic um that information can be
collected at various clinics deciding
which ones you want to basically do
those treatments um I think that's
information that is entirely possible as
QA medical lead I think you can do all
of these things it's timec consuming and
I know it's cumbersome believe me I I've
had enough
statistics I think we want to keep this
simple because the last thing you want
to do is have this paragraph bog us down
going forward with this legislation not
in six months but maybe in in two years
but I think it's viable
okay so what we want is you is for you
guys to figure out how we would write
this paragraph to State what the general
concept is to do this um and you can put
in all the qualifiers you can based upon
what data are you've been allowed to
have access to you know just whatever
qualifiers you want to put in here to to
you know meet the needs that you what
you believe you're capable of doing
is that
possible I haven't really de depart
dealt with the Department of Safety too
much I used to know I don't believe this
typically falls under my duties that
sign to write State legislation yeah I'm
saying maybe I can maybe I can have your
former
Trooper the chief of enforcement to to
write it because he's now getting
getting used to my asking these request
but I guess we given that I have no idea
that you people even
existed okay and apparently uh somebody
did when they wrote the Bill somebody
thought our our argument is that we
would not be in the position to write
anything currently um because we are
unaware of any programs that exist that
would collect all of the
information I have absolutely no doubt
in my mind there's no way you collect
all this of any juvenile records that
they want from the court right which is
prohibited by RSA one there you go okay
so you but you could go through this and
know what you can and can't do
right on one on a few small seconds yes
but there's other sections of this that
it's not our then I I don't put it in
saying inform I I want you to to um uh
pretend like you're Ai and you're just
going to go through in there and delete
out everything you can't do and
whatever's left of what you know you can
do is that
possible I know this is a task you're
not used to taking
on I'm not in a position to be writing
legislation for uh this committee or
this group uh but we would be willing to
work with them if they come up with
their own another set of but how would
she know what you can't so how about you
go through there and cross out
everything you can't
do how about about that can you cross
out what you don't think you can do I
mean I'm trying to how do I make this
dialogue you you're going to ask her to
rewrite something and she's writing it
in a vacuum because she doesn't know
anything what you can and can't do okay
only you guys know that so how do we how
do we solve this chicken of the egg how
do we to me the easiest thing for you to
do is go in there and cross out anything
that you you have no way of doing maybe
there nothing left that document what's
that which would be a lot of that
document we're we're not the ones who go
out and send out these surveys right
we're not reaching out to people this
information and that would be the
qualifier right saying that that it
would be need to be a mechanism that all
this information is being that the that
these assuming you would start out by
saying assuming what you're capable of
acquiring that data that you're capable
that that are are that you have been
able to receive I don't know what's what
the right qualifier how you would like
to to write
that I would argue that her I don't know
how our name of our uh Center came to be
oh you just want to be out of this bill
alog together now I get it I would argue
we're we're not the best position to
report on Health and Welfare outcomes
that not our responsibility or our job
okay perfect got it you one out I got it
thank you very much okay Kate where did
this where did this come from did he
come from you guys where did it come
from
yeah who is anybody in the room going to
claim this
paragraph I I know
but
is well let me put it this way I didn't
write
it no there's nobody in the room going
to claim ownership of this
paragraph
right because evidently no one told them
that they were in this
bill well obviously somebody they they
were here they got wind of it yeah know
what I'm saying they never got wind of
it until till
yesterday
so
um all right so I mean in would you be
offended if we take this out of the
bill so this is 318 f24 page 30 page
30 question I'm I'm assuming you would
be be the person who would be coach you
know cheering for this but in the
meantime while you look at it yes
representative collabro you have a
question wouldn't this be the purview of
DHHS I mean this is the data that we
collect that
somebody came yeah this I do have a hand
for
HHS former legal
counsel yes yeah that's right you were
in the room when that
happened okay get in speak to the mic
tell everybody who you
are you can turn the mic on yeah Paul
thank you do I have to hold it no okay
my name is Paul Tumi I'm former house
legal councel I'm a member of the
Cannabis Coalition I've been working
with marijuana policy project and ACLU
for years on these bills and probably
drafted a lot of um the bill that this
originally came from but not this
section but I agree with what the
representative just said that this is
really a function of Health and Human
Services and you could either just put
it in there and ask them to do a report
or take it completely out and address
address it with a separate I mean you
got two years to get some kind of a
report out of after reading the last
sentence I think this is the reason why
I was given to
them okay
Liz he he threw you guys under the bus
when he began his testimony he said the
chief of police asked for heroin
information and that's how he started
collecting this data do you know
anything about this
paragraph
you're going to deny that
okay okay all right
Kate what's that yes we should we can
delete it I feel it's mixed I feel you
have two different entities that you're
asking to provide information each of
them equally able to do so but they're
two different entities I what I find is
striking is how did how dides anybody
expect it to get paid for
so I'm not from the Department the
individual who is no she used to be used
to be with the health and human services
I I do want to clar so this information
has been in here from the very beginning
right obviously we want some indicators
because we want to know whether or not
there's an impact on many of these
things so I do import I do uh think um
the inclusion of some of this is
important a lot of this data though is
already available either from the
Department of Health and Human Service
or the department of safety so I think
it's just a matter the department of
safety has just made clear they don't
want to be in this bill they want out
and that they get their that whatever
data they get is people are nice enough
to give it to them but what motor
vehicle they don't have data on Motor
Vehicles that's who they were Department
safety okay um but I do believe that
some kind of data collection is really
important I would defer to the
Department of Health and Human Services
I think they have a lot of this data
can't speak till like if there would be
a fiscal note I don't I wouldn't take
the whole section out but well I'm going
to take the whole section out because I
don't know who's going to do
it do you have a friend you can call it
HHS to find out yeah he's here he just
stepped out I'll I'll ask him
okay all right does anybody else have
something else they want to point out
that's been in this bill all along
and representative Gibbs
uh yeah you just made the point that I
was going to make actually which is that
while this data would be useful to have
uh I don't think it's crucial to the
bill and maybe just delete that whole
paragraph
okay
great there he is oh yes there's
HHS
but so did did you know do you guys do
this now for the
atc's uh for the record my name name is
Michael Hol I'm the administrator of the
therapeutic cannabis program with the
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm happy to take your
questions do You' seen this paragraph
before uh yes I've seen the paragraph um
uh I believe this paragraph has been in
the bill in various Inc incarnations you
know for a number of years or versions
um we uh recently explored this a little
bit more because there was there's a
couple data points that HHS um uh feels
would be are important um especially
with with regard to um uh childhood
poisonings um and accidental ingestions
so we added there um added that in here
we also added in a provision um to when
you say added that in so you you were
actually helped contribute this oh yes I
I we were working I was working with uh
representative Lon on some of the
language that impacts HHS okay um so the
structure here has been in legislation
for some versions probably years long I
do not know who or wrote that the drug
monitoring initiative would publish all
this data so I don't know the origins of
that but based on what has been in this
bill all this time we're looking at the
data the data sets and we believe that
it's important to know uh if accidental
childhood ingestions increase after
legalization it's a critical piece that
you know prevention um uh Specialists
you know uh want to know about cannabis
legalization so that's the that was the
Genesis of my recent involvement in this
section um so we also added the the
provision that um Department of Safety
would collaborate with the people who
hold the data um the the entities
holding the data include ocme the office
of the chief medical examiner HHS and
there's a reference to graduation rate
so that's you know Department of
Education um obviously any data sharing
is going to require inou between
agencies um we do these uh on a regular
basis the collaboration requirement um
here in the statute would give us the
authority to collaborate and enter into
M and data sharing agreements with other
agencies um I do not know who is the
holder of all of these data sets um I
can go back to HHS and determine which
data sets we currently hold um and
report back to this committee if you
like um I I do not I'm not an expert in
all of these data sets but it is
important um for cannabis legalization
effort to establish Baseline Data before
the program starts so that we know the
impacts of cannabis legalization moving
forward after legalization you heard
about a reference from the CDC um by a
previous uh speaker um about uh before
and after with regard to Washington
State so uh from a public health
standpoint you know Baseline data and
you know what happens after legalization
is just critical information for the
state to have to know what the impact is
so I would I would urge this paragraph
be left in um and allow us to come back
with some uh some other information um
with regard to or more clarity on who
holds these data sets um and uh if we
can if there's another entity we can add
in that that other entity if these data
sets don't exist we'll you know we can
take them out but let's let us take a
first stab at you know who holds the
data and us being Health and Human
Services Health and Human servic okay so
I'm going to look forward you guys to
rewrite this paragraph based upon your
the Department's capabilities of getting
this
done we will work in collaboration with
the drug Department of Safety because
the the the requirement here is that the
department of safety's drug
monitoring uh
initiative publishes the data now again
I'm not I'm not an expert here I'll we
will collaborate with uh the the DMI um
on on publishing location um I don't
know if that's the best place or maybe
it is the best place so happy to get
back to you with some more information
but I can't commit to you know giving
you the the be all and all policy on
here I'm really looking for I'm just
looking for a department to do this okay
and I just got one Department that says
please do not make us do this so so I'm
ask I'm looking to Health and Human
Services now to take a look at this
paragraph this is why we don't come to
the meetings right you know because we
gotta sign
things in hindsight right so um
otherwise we would have just taken it
out otherwise we' just rip it out in
other words if I if we can't have
somebody who is willing to take it on
knows what you can and can't do okay and
the language could simply say is um have
a plan and how you're gonna go about
doing this like emmo you know getting
your you know letters of understanding
doing writing out that dialogue about
how you're going to best do it and uh
how the frequency you feel comfortable
doing it and the cost it's going to take
and all all that and I assume there must
be a fysal note attached to this I'm
happy to to to regroup with um our team
collaborate with the uh Department of
Safety staff um and uh determine uh and
give a recommendation on how best to uh
proceed with this element and rewrite
this paragraphs for next
week okay otherwise commit to doing my
otherwise it'll be gone and then you'll
have to wait till it gets on the Senate
side or or Ways and Means and maybe we
we will have some even if it's where
available language um you can put all
the qualifiers you want in here for me
excellent okay I'll take I'll take all
the qualifiers I just so you can at
least have a placeholder how's that
sounds good representative
Gibs I was just going to suggest that
since so many other states have already
legalized marijuana in so far as data
exists on these types of questions I
would assume that they have data why do
we need to represent why do we need to
reinvent the Wheel by collecting our own
data New Hampshire isn't that different
from Massachusetts or Maine or Vermont
uh I mean sure there are differences but
we're all human beings why not just look
for data from other
states I would just offer that many
states don't establish Baseline Data
before they legalize um and the the
Hallmark of this uh proposal is that New
Hampshire should establish Baseline data
to see change over
time thank you very much thank you see
you next
week represent do you have an opinion on
on this
paragraph sorry yes that uh paragraph
was in the amendment because there was
some more clarity about who would be
working with everybody so I will work
with them in order to come with an
amendment um there was one other if if
if we're good with this one there is one
other section as well where it been
raised in the hallway with me um it was
around the analment language and just
the idea that the way that it's written
there could be some uh confusion about
how to implement it and to just add the
words that um not no more than The
Possession limit but no more than the
current possession limit so that there's
not a question about whether it was at
the time of the conviction or currently
so I'll bring that language as an
amendment as well we can talk about it
at that point but I didn't want to
Blindside you with another section being
changed okay so what what works fine is
it would have the amendment drawn up yes
okay and then when uh the committee
takes up the sub when we take up the
subcommittee next week we can just vote
multiple amendments okay and then bundle
them together and send them off to
legisl services so by the time the
committee votes on it it will have the
final okay so to do that and stack
within this amendment so starting with
this one and then have the amendment on
you can put all the ones that you know
of yeah then yeah into one to to do that
that section f24 and then the analment
to add the current possession exactly
okay to just and let saying is it's okay
if they were separate if they had to
be okay because legislative Services can
handle that words we can vote multiple
amendments to a bill but that if you can
throw it all into one and get it all
done that's even better okay and if um I
I assume that any language we get on the
data collection is probably going to be
better than what we have exactly um so
well because we we we you know I don't
know how long you've been in the room
but yeah we're yeah we're you heard you
heard where we left it yes no I just
moved over so that I could have some of
that back conversation so we'll we'll
get the new language on f24 and then
just add that word current into the an M
which would add to that Amendment um and
just move forward from there for you
great thank you okay is there anything
else speak now or forever more hold your
piece are we G to be going into stuff
now or going into stuff now or next week
oh no no I
we we can't we don't have all the
Amendments that we need to do to
raise all concerns and stuff next week
or next time we talk what concerns do
you want to talk about well I don't have
a lot of time cuz I have to be somewhere
be in Berlin at five okay I don't know
how long is it Berlin that's way up
there it's two hours two hours leave
soon so that means you got to leave
right now right so I don't know if we
want to get into it now or well when
when did you when did you run down the
list and then I'll decide basically want
is there's one one one thing that I
really want changed
is I don't like the 15 the 15 I can deal
with that what I don't like is the idea
that there's just this REM meting or the
commission will meet every five years or
whatever to no that's gone she says it's
now every
year she had I might have Miss that when
I went to the restroom but well that's
okay well then fil me in what was
said uh it's she you're you want to
repeat it so why don't you stay here so
you let me hear what you what you said
and I'll tell you
what I was thinking and I'll my meeting
so uh the way that it it now is in this
amendment is that it's 15 stores and
after 30 30 months after enactment they
would assess whether or not there needs
to be more and then to reassess it every
year annually annually but there's no
there's no there's no tripping
mechanisms to say that based on this
condition it would increase it leaves it
entirely to Theiss so that that is not
exactly what I I think we need because
I've raised this with you John I don't
like the idea of creating medallions
this is going to create The Medallion
system or the Montana liquor right I got
it so what I like to avoid that is to
have some fixed number that every 30
months or three years or whatever they
are become available so maybe there's
three licenses that become available so
how did you like my language about
market area the market area analysis and
the commission would then do yeah I I
would rather have it just be fixed
because the market decide if
there's or fixes fixes veto bait is what
veto governor with veto if if you put
but see the the reality of it is and I
think that this cons I know there's a I
don't like most of this but I'm like
willing to compromise in much of it but
and I and I talked to her and I think a
lot of good is in here I raised the
analment thing that I thought was
confusing because that's like the key
part for me but this is the other key
part for me okay creating Medallion
system is bad this is going to do that
we know it's going to do it we know the
people who get these licenses are going
to do their damnest to build a mode
around their businesses we've seen it in
industry and after industry
there's a huge ton of literature of
economic history that shows plenty of
examples of this happening and we're
setting it up now so but when I had my
paragraph what I thought I was
brilliant was that you mean the one you
gave us last week and then we told the
new one was coming I didn't read it so I
can go back and look so anyway so it's
the yellow section and and if you like a
copy of it you can have it here and in
it it says that the commission would do
a market
analysis and so therefore would expand
make recommendation for expansion based
on that market analysis so it could come
back and say we need another 30
stores I I'll look at it I mean it seems
to me like doing the market analysis
opens a door for them to be influenced
by okay well now you get back to the
what the governor wants was the that the
no uh
lobbying no lobbying you know you that
that nobody who who's been given a store
is allowed to Lobby the
legislature that that's which is not in
here you didn't put it in here at all
I'm just telling you that's the reason
why the governor did that okay well so
you're ask you're basically saying he's
worried if he's worried you're saying
the governor's right if he's worried
about their them
lobing around their industry then then
he then he should be and not want to
veto my
suggestion okay all right he was working
about them being the lobbyist to making
sure that that I think that they should
have a right to Lobby in in a lot of
ways they should they shouldn't have a
right to create build walls around their
their businesses okay um all right
anyways we can bring up next time I have
to be somewhere all right what other
complaint what other concerns you have
or is that that that is it like the
other ones have been largely addressed
but that one that one's like a key
sticking point that one and the en
helment thing were the two okay and uh I
mean it sounds like we're gonna take
care of and um I I in terms of expansion
and putting in hard numbers in into the
legislation uh it's extremely
problematic I mean you're you're being
variable about your numbers about what
numbers you
want what does that even mean I'm being
variable what do you mean you're saying
you're saying okay I want uh five stores
every five years or you 10 stores or
want 30 stores or how many stores do you
want and what time period were you
thinking I just want there to be a
mechanism where if the market wants more
stores they can get it and your language
does not state that your language could
vary in 30 years from now here's your
here's your project have your come up
with your solution that you solution
what's that what's your solution you
just a mechanism so mechanism build
every every three years every three
years a certain number number we can
decide the number what number tell us
the number now we'll say three three
three licenses become available every
every three years fine if there's no
Market available for them then then they
they won't be taken but if there are
then we know that that what if there's
more okay what if the market wants more
so represent are you okay with every
three years another three Stores um I
think we'd want to look at what the
analysis of what the actual Market
capacity is if it's actually a market
clearing um scenario 55 stores that
would take a long time to get from that
15 to 55 but I do like the idea of
opening up a certain number of licenses
because this is going to be a market as
it evolves I don't if we have a number
where they're not all taken I think
that's actually a good position to be in
um so I'd be happy to discuss what a
number would make would make sense that
that's
fine she going to be doing the amendment
you can work that sounds good all right
and uh additionally I had one other
thing about the lobbying um we had the
discussion earlier today with chairs and
vice chairs about the idea of state
employees um so state employees are able
to come and speak and Lobby to us um
it's actually exempt from lobbying yes
so the idea of having a carve out for
franchises would be a problem um anybody
who has is employed based upon it with
their testimony would need to register
as a lobbyist but if you're just having
if you're a volunteer then you don't so
we already have clear language around
lobbying and trying to change it around
one industry would be highly problematic
we have areas that are very much a
medallion system in the state and I
think that doing special treatment here
instead of others is problematic fair
enough all right so but you will work
with him on his expansion language okay
now is there anything
more all
right